All right. What is up y'all? Thank you
for being here and welcome. Hope
everybody's doing well tonight.
Important discussion ahead um as we will
be discussing the atonement
specifically what exactly atonement is
according to scripture and then
examining Adventist teaching. In light
of that, I want to start by saying this
is not going to be a discussion
regarding various atonement theories
or whether or not one theory is superior
over and against another. The purpose of
tonight's discussion is to show the 7th
Advenist Church does not merely present
an alternative theory amongst a host of
what could be considered orthodox
theories. The Adventist Church will tell
you that they affirm substitutionary
atonement, not to be confused with penal
or legal substitution, but that isn't
what is in question tonight. So, if you
are an Adventist, before you start
commenting or saying we are
cherrypicking one atonement theory over
and against another, nope, that is not
the problem. The problem is very
specific teachings regarding atonement,
period. Regardless of what theory you
may ascribe to, I have been very vocal
on this particular issue for a number of
years as well as from this platform and
we will continue to be vocal on this
topic. I went into this uh on Monday's
video for those of you that may have
watched that. Uh tonight will be a far
deeper dive and discussion because the
Adventist church is not Christian. If
you're an Adventist lay person, pastor,
leader, insert, whatever title, we do
not hate you. But in the words of one of
my favorite theologians,
John Chrism,
we must not mind insulting men if by
respecting them we offend God.
We must not mind insulting men if by
And that's really the heart of the
matter. So if what we say tonight
offends you, that's not the intent. Not
here to to dog on anybody personally or
hate on anybody.
But we are willing to shoot you straight
and sound the alarm. And we're going to
let the chips fall where they may. Our
prayer is that you would abandon the SDA
church's false doctrines and come to
know the true Christ and his gospel.
Just like you all believe it's your
mission to witness to Christians if
you're being honest, which is your
primary focus and target as well. With
that said, I want to remind you all that
you can visit answering adventism.com.
This is a resource for you. Yes, you the
viewer.
You can access a plethora of resources,
namely our extensive library of Q&A
articles. All of these categorized, or
you can use our super handy search bar
here. You can either type in topics,
you can type in hot phrases and words,
you can type in things like
contradiction
to your heart's desire. If you don't see
your question in the library, you can
always come down. There is a contact
button at some point down the page. ask
a new question. You can do it right
there if you don't see your question.
But you can come on here and browse all
sorts of categories.
And when you come in here, it's going to
have all the hyperlinks for you to
quickly, easily access scripture. You
just hover over it, it'll pop up right
for you. If the full thing doesn't show,
just click more or you can really just
click wherever you are on the link. But
use this resource. This is for you all.
I've said it before and I'll say it
again. We have arguably the most
extensive documented and sourced
resource in this space. There are
hundreds, if not thousands of primary
source materials hyperl on every page,
giving you the easiest of access to the
horse's own mouth to verify yourself
quickly, easily to study, and then put
the information to use because that's
what it's here for. It's not here to
just dunk on Seventh Day Adventism. We
are trying to reach Seventh Day
Adventists. We want to equip Christians
to reach these people because they need
it. Seventh Day Adventism is not
Christian and this platform is
predominantly geared towards Christians.
We want to equip Christians to take this
information and put it to use in your
apologetic. Reach these people. Engage
online. Engage boots on the ground.
That's what this is here for. It's not
just to dunk on Seventh Day Adventism.
So, please make use of the site. It's
our gift to you. You can also partner
with us here as well if you would like.
Drop us a question. Like I said, if you
don't see it in the library, as well as
access the wall of memes. Do not forget
the wall of memes.
You can share these. We're adding new
memes constantly for those of you that
that is your thing. Also,
I want to give a big shout out, very,
very, very big shout out
to all of the individuals who have
partnered with us financially.
You guys make all of this happen. Your
contributions are reaching real people,
real families, and making a real
difference. And I mean that. And I know
that because these people contact me.
And we're only just getting started.
We're not even a year in yet, folks. So,
thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Whatever amount, $5, $1, $10, $100,
whatever it may be. Thank you.
We will have an update on this in
October for our oneyear anniversary,
hate mail, great disappointment
celebration, Palooa special thingy,
whatever you want to call it. But thank
you again for partnering with us. During
that stream, we're going to share a
number of the testimonies that people
have shared privately, not their names
obviously, but nevertheless, we're going
to show you that you guys are making
this possible. Even people who are not
financially donating, the prayers,
everything, everything. We appreciate
all of it. Thank you. Because I never
anticipated going into this, I don't
want to go on a soap box here, but I
never anticipated when I started this
the amount of support, encouragement,
prayers, etc. because we're making a big
difference. So, thank you. With me
tonight, though, is no stranger to the
platform. Jim was on a number of months
ago at this point, I think about four
months or so, um, to discuss the false
gospel of Adventism, which was a great
stream. He has a YouTube channel called
Academy Apologia which deals with
apologetics to various groups um
Mormons, Muslims, uh non-Christian
groups, but he's taken particular
attention and focus to 7th Day
Adventism. So, go check his channel out
if you have not. He's got some
welldocumented extensive information
over there. I love the fact that he's
citing from most of the time original
books of antiquity, that sort of thing.
So, if that's your fancy, go check his
channel out as well. It is linked in the
description box down below. With that
said, brother, welcome back.
Thank you for being here.
Sorry, your mute or uh your mic was uh
your mic was muted. Oh, there we go. All
right. No, no, thank you. And it's glad
to be I'm glad to be here again. Yes.
So,
we're going to do this in three parts,
folks. There are three primary parts
we're going to break this down into.
The first is going to be discussing the
atonement biblically. What is the
atonement biblically? So, first Jim,
let's define our terms, shall we?
What is the atonement according to
scripture?
All right. So, you know, yeah, when most
people, I want to say most Christians
are faced with the question that you
just asked, they often think of the
cross of Christ. Yep. And and what
happened there, the death of Christ. And
so, let me give you just a couple
scripture verses that those of you
taking notes, and do take notes. Uh 1
Corinthians 15:3, which is part of the
gospel message. The apostle says, "I
delivered to you of first importance
what I also received that Christ died
for our sins according to the
scripture." That's what we often think
of when we atonement. Another one and I
hope to explore a little bit later as we
get in is Colossians 1:22. It says this,
"He, this is Christ, has now reconciled
in his body of flesh uh by his death."
We are reconciled
in the body of Christ through his death.
But so again, that's what we common we
commonly think. We commonly think of the
cross of Christ, the death of Christ. We
think of the blood, but you can't forget
the resurrection
is part of the package. And again, 1
Corinthians 15:17, and if Christ has not
been raised, your faith is feudal. These
off these often go hand in hand together
in the scriptures. Matter of fact, if
you were to stand back and and do a you
know 2,000 foot view of the scriptures
and think about what we're talking about
tonight, the faith of the saints is the
death, burial, and resurrection of
Christ. They all go hand in hand. So the
atonement is in that package. One last
one I'll I'll throw in there would be uh
1 Peter 1:3 where it says um it's about
the resurrection of Christ from the
dead. So yeah, we often think of it's
just the atonement. Now like I said, the
message of the the Christian church is
the faith of the Christian church. The
true Christian church is the gospel and
that's the death, burial, and
resurrection of Christ of which the
atonement is is part of that message.
And of course, what's not part of that
message is three angels each with gospel
messages called the everlasting gospel
or revelation 14, etc. That's not part
of it. Um, so anyway, when we when we
think of just atonement and we're going
to narrow it down, yeah, that's what we
we typically think of the cross, the
blood of Christ, but I want to say don't
forget about the resurrection, too.
Yeah. And there's some formal
terminology which we'll get into next,
but you you nailed it. The atonement
centers around the person and work of
Jesus in his death, burial, and
resurrection.
That's what the atonement centers on.
Correct? That's it. Yeah. So the second
question to you then to get even more
specific because like I mentioned when
we talk about atonement, we have formal
terms that are associated with things
around the atonement. And this is
important as well when we're discussing
groups like Seventh Adventism because
oftentimes at the general level, they're
going to say, "Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. We
agree with that. Yep. Yep. We we believe
that." But when we get more specific and
granular on terms is when we start to
see where the differences lie. So my
next question to you is going to be,
what does the term propitiation mean in
scripture?
All right. So I'm going to get to that,
but let me do this first. By the way,
you open up your Bible, everybody, and
you search for the word atonement, odds
are you're not going to find it. You
look for the word atonement in your in
your ESV in your revised version, it's
not there. Your KJV, I think it has it
only once, and I think it's Romans 5.
So, it's not a common term. So like
Miles said, there are other terms we're
going to explore that mean that where we
derive the word atonement from largely
when we in our vernacular when we speak
of it. One of is propitiation. Like I'm
going to read to you first John 4:10. It
says in this love not that we have loved
God but that he loved us and sent his
son to be the propitiation for our sins.
Not a word we use very much in English.
propitiation.
The Greek word is hilosmos.
And let me see if I can can I share my
screen here? You can. Down at the
bottom, just select to share your screen
and I will bring it up. There we go.
And there we go. You should see the
PowerPoint slide. Perfect. Yep. So, you
can full screen that if you'd like. All
right.
Do I have I have control to full screen
that? Yeah. Just do it from just do it
from PowerPoint. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Sorry about that. Oh, all good.
There we go.
All right.
So, it didn't full screen on our end,
but that's that should be okay. That
should be okay. I'll bring it out fully,
so it's fine. We should be able to to
function. Funny. Yeah. Yeah. I got it in
I got it in show mode.
All right. Well, you you can see the uh
the PowerPoint slides.
Yep. All right.
Either that or it's or or you know what?
It's actually sharing the wrong screen
is what it's doing. It's all good. We
can see it. Yeah, it's fine. It's fine.
We'll we'll work with that. So, 1 John
2:2 First John 4:10 that I quoted from
propitiation. Here it is in the G only
used twice in the entire New Testament.
Like I said, not a word we use very
much. So, here it is in in a lexicon I
use all the time by Loanita and and the
Greek word is uh pilasmos and it means
what? The means by which the sins are
forgiven. Now, pay attention to that.
The sins are forgiven. Not will be
forgiven. Not will be forgiven in 1844
are forgiven. And it means what? The
second underline. Christ himself is the
means by which the sins are forgiven. So
when it says propitiation for sins,
that's exactly what he's talking about.
He is the means by which sins are
forgiven.
Um,
another another account of that is in
Romans 3:24 and 3:25.
And it might just might be easier just
to do what we did last time. And let me
just read that to you. And it talks
about justification. That's another word
we use sometimes we don't think about.
By the way, if you're a Christian,
you're only justified once, right? Uh it
says and Paul says in Romans 3:24 and25
but we are justified by his grace as a
gift through the redemption that's in
Christ whom God put forward as here it
is again propitiation for our blood. Now
this is a little different variant of
the word propitiation that was used in
first John. It's only used twice. So
this one here is a slight variant on
that. But let's look at that word here
in uh in Romans. Let me I'll share this
screen with you here.
Okay.
So, you can see here it's it's Roman 3
3:24 here on on the bottom. And what's
it say? It's the free gift. Now, what is
propitiation? It's the free gift of his
grace in delivering them. There we go
again. Delivering. You have been
delivered through Christ and you are put
right with him. this whole idea of an
atonement happening later and not now
because the Christians reading Romans
3:24, 1 John 4:10, 1 John 2:2 knew when
they were talking about propitiation of
our sins, it was something that was
happening right then and right now. So
that's what propitiation means. Let me I
I want to jump to the next word. Since I
used justification in Romans 3:24, you
are justified. And you're only
justified, like I said, you're only
justified the one time. And so when when
Paul is speaking of justification,
you can see the word here. It means
what? To release or set free with the
implied analogy, the process of freeing
a slave. To set free, liberate, deliver.
You're justified. You are delivered. And
by the way, so when you are, and it's in
this kind of language of a slave, when
you're set free, you're only set free
once and you are set free. It's not
you're going to be set free later. You
are set free right then, right now, that
time. So when Paul says in 3:24 and
3:25, you are justified by the
propitiation of his blood, you are set
free for good forever by what Christ did
on the cross. That is the point that he
is making here in these in these verses.
Yeah. And it I think that we're not
going to necessarily talk about that in
depth tonight. We talked about that a
few weeks ago, folks. Maybe I can have
you back, Jim, for for a discussion on
that because that's another really
important one, especially when it comes
to Adventism. Um, this is a a a staunch
point of difference between us and not
just say 7th Adventists, but say the
church in the east, the Roman Catholic
Church, etc. This idea of an ongoing
justification leading to a point of
final justification. The Adventist
church wants to use the term uh
esqueological justification. This idea
of a second tier or a second phase. And
uh the grammar around that is what
you're saying is clear that this is a
one-time action on God's part. Correct.
AB: Absol. Absolutely. You know, and
we're going to see other scriptures are
going to say exactly the same thing.
This is a one-time and immediate and
forever action. That's it. Yeah. Yep.
Couple things on propitiation just
because we were on there previously. Um
that I think are important to bring up
as well. Um, so you talked about how and
and this is common in the Greek
language. This is also common in the
English language. I'm not a Greek
grammarian by any uh stretch of the
imagination, but um you have uh
conjugations of the phrase and and and
different contexts and usages and those
sorts of things. But just the root word
itself, propitiation, refers to the
turning away of the wrath of God as the
just judgment of our sin by God's own
provision of the sacrifice of Jesus
Christ on the cross. Uh it quite
literally means to appease God's wrath,
the word itself in Greek, propitiation.
Um people today don't necessarily like
that.
uh there's a there's a big um growing
movement of people out there who abhore
the idea of God having wrath or anger
etc. But uh nevertheless um when the
scriptures are teaching uh
it's often conflated I've heard a number
of people who take umbrage with this um
they conflate the notion of the pagan
deistic idea of a bloodthirsty deity um
with what's going on here. Um but that's
not actually what's going on in
scripture. Um it's actually quite
different. It's that God's anger is a
product of his justice and who he is by
nature. So he has to uh the result of
sin is that there must be penalty and
judgment for such. So when the Bible
talks about propitiation, it's not
talking about some sort of I've heard
people use the pjorative of divine
cosmic child abuse. Um when in reality,
well, no, Jesus is the free will
offering. We're going to talk about that
a little bit tonight, or at least I am.
Um Jesus gave of himself freely. There
there's nothing here regarding that. It
has to do with the fact that because sin
has to be punished by God, there has to
be some sort of penalty that's paid for
that. He can't just let it slide or he
wouldn't be who he is by nature. So the
second person of the Godhead, Christ,
the word willfully bore that such that
God can then both be the just and the
justifier where you just were in Romans
3:23-26.
So he punishes sin, but he also
graciously saves some. He's the just and
the justifier. But also, and this is
super important on tonight's topic,
the word itself, look it up folks for
yourself, this doesn't take having a
Greek background or anything. You can
look this up in the any sort of Greek
lexicon. It has to do with the mercy
seat. Specifically, the word has to do
with the action of what was done on the
mercy seat. The act of the blood being
sprinkled
onto the mercy seat. And when we study
what was done when the blood was
sprinkled onto the mercy seat in terms
of atonement,
you have complete forgiveness.
You have the complete remission of sins.
That is what essentially brings about
true forgiveness of sins. So the word
propitiation has to do with forgiveness,
which brings me to my next question,
which is
Whoops.
What does the term forgiveness mean in
scripture, Jim? All right. So, I mean,
you've already seen that forgiveness of
sins is an act. It's immediate
occurrence by it's by faith in Christ
and based upon his work that he did on
the cross. Now, this does not mean you
are righteous, but it does mean that God
is looking as you're being looked at by
God as righteous only because of Christ
and and that's it. So, you're not
declared righteous. So, you know that
you're some kind of righteous. No,
you're no, you're not. You're still a
sinner. You always will be on this side
of the grave. That's just the way that's
the way it is. But um it's the means by
which to forgiveness is the means by
which God's going to look at you and
then and and then declare you righteous
though you're really not righteous. So
to begin to be forgiven of of your sins,
it's an it's an it's an act of it's all
your sins by the way. It's the sins
past, present, and future. One thing on
that really quick, Jim, just really
quick because there's going to be a lot
of people that take objection with that,
especially the Adventist, especially the
Adventist church that has a concept and
teaching of, well, you're forgiven up to
the point of your baptism and you're you
get a clean slate, etc. Folks, all of
your sins were future to the cross. Not
just the future from today into the
future. All of your sins were future to
the cross.
So, I just wanted to put that out there
because that's a common objection that
people make and they don't realize.
They'll often say, "Well, it can't be
your future sins when you know, and
well, all your sins were future sins to
the cross." Go ahead. And you know, and
that's why I put that in here. That's
why I said what I said because I know
the Seventh Day Adventist is thinking,
well, it's only, you know, it's only my
sins after I come to Christ that in my
term of probation that uh that I need
to, you know, repent, etc. No, that's
not what the scriptures teach. And I'm
going to show you something here to
prove that. We're going to look at First
John 17. So, when you are forgiven of
all of your sins, it means all of your
sins. It's a totality of your sins. As
you can see here,
we'll get we'll get First John 17. I've
got it up. All right. I've got it up.
Actually, we'll bring yours up because
it looks like you uh or I thought maybe
you had something uh yeah specific
specific, but we are we're going to roll
over to the next slide. So, okay. What
does and you know when I look at this
and you look at this for cleanses us
from all sin. Well, what does all mean?
You know, I I went and looked up the
Greek word for all. And here and here's
the Greek word for all. And it it's used
quite often. Here's look at look at what
I underlined. The totality of an object,
mass, collection, extension, all
everything, whole.
When first John says we are forgiven for
all sins, he is not saying, well, and
there's the Greek word. Look at it. It
doesn't say you're forgiven of sins at a
certain point of time. It's the totality
of of sins. Period. That's what the
scriptures are teaching you. I know in
the seventh day Adventist head, they're
not forgiven of all their sins when they
when they come to their investigative
judgment, Levitical priest, Jesus. But
true Christians that come to Christ are
forgiven of all of their sins. That's
what First John is teaching. The Greek
word for all means all, the totality of
them. It sets no boundaries on that
word. So, you just saw the word all and
you saw the word sins and all means all.
That's it. Uh, by the way, and and and
and I as I'm thinking about this, I know
that some are thinking, well, uh, you
know, especially in Adventism, there's
this tendency of, you know, this sinless
perfectionism
or uh or I have to keep the
commandments, which means I won't sin or
I shouldn't sin. I need to fight that. I
need I need to strive to become sinless.
Well, first John 1:8 says, "If we have
no sin, we deceive ourselves and the
truth is not in us." I often say to
Adventists, really, you're trying to
achieve a state of sinlessness in which
First John says, "If you do achieve that
state, the truth isn't in you. You're a
sinner." And then he goes on to say in
verses 9 and 10 of First John, you know,
if we confess our sins, he's faithful
and just to forgive us. Yeah, you're
going to have sins. Confess your sins.
He's going to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness. It says then in verse
10 it says if we say we have not sinned,
we make him a liar.
You are not going to keep the
commandments. You're not going to
achieve a state of perfection. If you
do, you are trying to achieve a state of
being a liar according to first John
1:10. You can't do it. Or if you do, you
will achieve the state of the scriptures
declaring you a liar. So no, you're
going to sin. All Christians are going
to sin. you will not achieve this state
of sinless perfection uh etc. And what
happens when we do sin? Well, that's 1
John 2:1. We have an advocate with the
father, Jesus Christ. 1 Timothy 2:5,
there's one God and one mediator between
God and man, the man Christ Jesus.
Christians are going to sin and will
repent of their sins. Well, and this
gets into a deeper discussion, Jim,
about what sin is, folks. Again, you can
go on answering adventism.com. I have a
long article on this breaking this down.
I don't want to um spend the whole night
going into that, but you can check that
out just by going to the search bar on
the website, what is sin? Um, but that
really is the key issue here coming from
the 7th Adventist background because
they're going to hear you say, um, you
can't achieve what they've resurrected
or erected in their own minds as the
standard and they don't understand the
depth of sin and what sin really
actually is. In their minds, it's for
example, second commandment, I didn't
bow down to any statues today.
It runs that low. It's not, well, did I
put anything in my thinking, thoughts,
actions, words before God today?
Anything at any moment. Jesus was
obedient to the point of death, even
death on a cross. His passive and active
obedience. Nope. There's no concept of
that in Adventism. Zero. The what is
needed. You mentioned this earlier about
the fact that we don't have a
righteousness in and of ourselves.
Philippians 3 9-10. The only reason
we're able to be seen united to Christ,
union with Christ, which is really the
lynch pin and the hinge of the gospel
message, is being united to Jesus
Christ. The only reason that we're able
to even be seen as remotely righteous is
because of Christ, not anything in
ourselves. Now, that doesn't mean that a
person just then immediately goes,
"Well, I can just live in lensiousness."
Well, no. That doesn't take into account
the new birth, being made a new
creature. There's a whole number of
factors that you have to also include in
that sort of thinking that it's just not
logical to then think that a person who
is born again will know they're not
going to have that desire. But the
reality is they still fall short because
the standard is loving God perfectly
with every thought, word, deed, and
motive. That's the standard 247. That's
what Jesus Christ did. And when you have
his righteousness imputed to you, you
can then be seen as righteous. God being
the just and the justifier, he punish
sin in Christ on the cross while also
imputes his righteousness to those that
are in him.
That's how the whole function can take
place.
the and you're right, the whole basis of
the 7th day Adventist concept of sin and
repentance and the investigative
judgment that comes from this book here
which I just read again chapter I think
it's 24 on the investigative judgment.
Yep. And and something I hadn't thought
about for a while when I was reading it.
So the basis of of the whole atonement
theory and Adventism comes from that
book. And when I read that chapter,
Ellen White over and over and over is
talking about angels recording your good
deeds and your bad deeds. Yep. That's a
worksbased.
Do did I do good today? Did I kick the
dog? Oh no, I'm a bad person, you know,
or a bad thought about no that whole
foundation here that she built this
concept of what's right and wrong and I
even going to say sin. She doesn't even
uh she expresses it as just doing good
deeds and bad deeds and some angel
recording them and that's it. So when
your foundation is as rotten as it is
here in 7th day Adventism
with what she wrote in that book then
you're not it what comes out the other
end it's not going to be good and it's
not. Yeah. And and again folks the
article on the website goes into this in
more detail. Um but in their minds sin
is a behavioral issue exclusively.
While I will agree, yes, there are
behavioral aspects to to sin, choices
and actions, etc., that's not where the
line's drawn. It doesn't end there. It
goes beyond that. Now, they're going to
quote first John. They love the book of
1 John. They're going to say 1 John 3:9.
Sin is transgression of the law.
But that's where they draw the line.
When in reality, that's not where
scripture draws the line. Scripture
draws the line much further out than
that. I mean, Jesus himself draws the
line further in Matthew 5. He expounds
upon the letter of the law. He says, "If
you've even looked at a woman with lust,
you've committed adultery in your
heart." The law doesn't say that. The
the letter of the law does not state
that. Jesus is explaining it goes a lot
deeper than merely the letter of the
law. But I would argue they're not even
keeping the letter of the law, which
folks, a video that's going up on Monday
is addressing that specific thing with
regards to the first commandment. Now, I
want to tack on to what you had said
regarding forgiveness and bring up a
couple of verses here. Um, because I
think it's important for
uh people to kind of see what's going on
here. Um, you mentioned that forgiveness
deals with all of your sins, past,
present, future, and that's exactly it,
Jim. That's the the hinge. As somebody
who came from the world of Adventism, I
can tell you that is the hinge upon
which the issue lies here. Because in
the Adventist system, forgiveness is
really more about, well, you're
pardoned, but you're on probation.
It's a totally different way of seeing
things. And they think if you disagree
with this, well, you you're you're
advocating then for lawlessness. Well,
no, that's a false dichotomy. Now, why
are you jumping into the other ditch of
the other extreme? Be a little bit more
balanced. Understand that the Christian
life is a constant war. Jesus taught his
disciples to pray daily asking
forgiveness for their sins. The Lord's
prayer. I'm part of a Christian
tradition where we aim to recite that
like the dedicay says three times a day.
Not out of some sort of legalistic
reasoning, but just to keep at the
forefront of the mind the posture that
I'm to take before God. I fall short.
It's only in Christ. We're going to talk
about this a little bit more later,
folks. But union with Christ, that's the
key. Well, in the new covenant, when it
comes to forgiveness, what did Jeremiah
prophesy?
He says here
31-34,
prophesying about the new covenant.
Behold, the days are coming, declares
the Lord, when I will make a new
covenant with the house of Israel, the
house of Judah, not like the covenant
that I made with their fathers on the
day when I took them by the hand to
bring them out of the land of Egypt, my
covenant that they broke, though I was
their husband, declares the Lord. For
this is the new covenant that I'll make
with their house. Now, God further than
just this, but this will suffice for the
point.
I will write or uh sorry for this is the
covenant that I'll make with the house
of Israel after those days, declares the
Lord. I'll put my law within them and
I'll write it on their hearts. I will be
their God and they shall be my people.
Now Adventists love that verse. They say
the law of God is then written on the
heart, which we're not getting into that
tonight, but I will be their God, and
they shall be my people. And no longer
shall shall each one teach his neighbor
and each his brother, saying, "Know the
Lord, for they shall all know me from
the least of them to the greatest,"
declares the Lord. Now, this is the
kicker. For I will forgive their
iniquity, and I will remember their sins
no more. Now, the author of Hebrews
quotes this. I believe it's Hebrews
10:17. We're going to get into that
later tonight, but he quotes this. A
promise of the new covenant is that God
remembers our sins no more.
God remembers our sins no more. That is
key and tied to propitiation,
forgiveness, all of the things that
you've brought up from the Greek
language.
God remembers our sins no more. That is
a key promise of the new covenant. Those
that are united to the Lord Jesus Christ
by faith, given the spirit as a down
payment, a seal of their salvation, it's
the earnest money, the down payment of
God's promise to the individual. All of
the benefits of Christ are yours. This
is one of the benefits.
Hebrews 1 1-4 or there's Hebrews 10:17.
Again, the author quoting from where we
just read. Then he adds because the
author is talking about in that chapter,
well, the whole book really, how the new
covenant is better than the old. The
Adventist church wants to keep pointing
us back to Sinai to Moses.
No, new covenant better. It's got better
promises. It's the true fulfillment of
what the old was just a shadow of. But
nevertheless, Hebrews 1 1-4, my pastor
just preached on this as we start
through the book of Hebrews verse by
verse this past Lord's day. Hebrews 1
1-4. Long ago at many times in many
ways, God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets. But in these last days, he's
spoken to us by his son. Ellen White
twists this scripture to her own demise
as she is currently unless she repented
in predition.
inserted herself in there instead of the
Lord Jesus Christ abominably so whom he
appointed to the to heir of all things
talking about his ascension
even before the ascension but at his
ascension we're going to talk about that
tonight as well through whom he also
created the world means he's Yahweh
Isaiah 44:24 Yahweh alone created all
things he is the radiance of the glory
of God and the exact imprint of his
nature
he's not a lesser being or deity
adventist
like Ellen White taught almost like
monarchianism that he's sub he he's
eternally subordinate to the father. No,
he's not. He's eternally well, we're not
going to get into all that, but he is
eternally equal with the father by
nature, his ontos, his being. And he
upholds the universe by the word of his
power. After making, now this is the
key, Jim. This is the key.
After making purification for sins,
Sorry, I annunciated that word a little
funny, but for a a point.
Now, this is is so important. Adventists
do not understand this at all. At all
what he's about to say here, this verse
decimates Seventh Day Adventism
after making purification for sins. Look
the word purification up, folks. He sat
down at the right hand of the majesty on
high. The the Levitical priest never sat
down. The work was never finished.
Christ made purifications for sins and
he sat down. This is then told to you
over five times in the book of Hebrews.
The original Jewish convert audience
that this was written to to keep them
from Judaizing and going back to the old
things like the seventh day Sabbath and
the old sacrifices etc.
He tells you he sat down. That audience
would have known. That is a drastic
difference. The work of dealing with sin
is finished.
Having become much superior to the
angels as the name as he has inherited
is much excellent than theirs. Talking
about his exaltation. Again, this goes
to the Psalms. The author is going to
recote this again. Psalm 110. To which
of the angels did he say, sit at my
right hand? That's what he goes into in
verses 8, 9, 10, etc.
Hebrews 9:23-26
Jesus put sin away at the cross just
like it said in terms of purification.
Thus it was necessary for the copies of
the heavenly things. This is after
because he's making compare and contrast
between the Levitical ironic priesthood
and the Mchisedcian priesthood of Christ
after talking about what the Levitical
priest had to do sprinkling everything
with blood because he was a sinner and
the work that he was doing was
typological and just a shadow.
But in the antitype, thus it was
necessary for the copy of the heavenly
things to be purified with these rights,
but the heavenly things themselves with
better sacrifices. We're going to talk
about this word tonight, Jim, because
this is a subtle twisting of the SDA
church.
The plural versus the singular of this
phrase sacrifices is huge.
But the heavenly things themselves with
better sacrifices than these. For Christ
has entered not into holy places made
with hands. That doesn't merely mean,
oh, a human built it. No, it's talking
about a building.
Because the holy places made with hands
were only a shadow of the true things.
He entered into heaven itself now to
appear in the presence of God on whose
behalf Jim
believers,
his people. Christ is mediating for his
people. Nor was it to offer himself
repeatedly. Again, the compare and
contrast as the high priest enters the
holy places every year with blood not
his own. the blood of bulls, goats,
calves, for then he would have had to
suffer repeatedly since the foundation
of the world. But as it is, this is the
the kicker, folks, he has appeared once
for all the end of the ages to put the
uh to put away sin by the sacrifice of
himself. The one sacrifice put sin away
at the cross.
Hebrews 10 1-4. I mentioned it earlier
or sorry, um we we'll talk about that
one later. We talked about Hebrews 1
1-4, but we'll talk about Hebrews 10 1-4
a little bit later. It compares the
Levitical work to Jesus Christ's work
and how completely different it is. So,
we'll get into that a little bit more
later, but in that same chapter, Hebrews
10 11-18, the blood of animals, he says,
could never take away sins, but Jesus's
did. Again, folks, if you're just
joining the stream, we're talking about
forgiveness and what forgiveness
actually is. And it's that sin is
actually taken away. Sin is removed. Sin
is expated. The word that you had up
earlier in the the lexicon, I I believe
it was the lexicon, um it had the term
expated with atonement, the removal of
sin. We're going to talk about that some
as well a little bit later. But Jesus
Christ, unlike the blood of bulls and
goats, which had to be administered
repeatedly over and over and over
because it could never take sin away,
Jesus's did. And the author explains
that the sacrifice of Christ, unlike the
Levitical sacrifices, could never
perfect a person that it was made for.
That's why it had to be done over and
over and over again. And so you
mentioned earlier the idea of Christ's
single application which is so important
here because
the single sacrifice of Christ does
perfect those that it was made for which
is why he can be seated not standing
dealing with sin. His sacrifice can
actually purify the conscience. We're
going to talk about this as well tonight
or at least I am. um it can actually
perfect the the conscience of the
person. Whereas the blood of bulls and
goats could only cover those things, but
the constant sacrificing was a reminder
of the people's sins. We don't have that
anymore because Christ has removed our
sin from us. Which is why we can have a
cleansed conscience and come to God with
boldness and assurance like the book of
Hebrews tells us. And we can come before
God knowing that we are accepted
essentially in Christ Jesus. So that
leads me to the final question before we
transition into our next part and that
is what does it mean Jim
what does it mean
sorry what does it mean to be reconciled
to God because that's another hot issue
with them what does it mean to be
reconciled it's another term almost
synonymous with uh atonement that we've
been talking about tonight atonement
propitiation
you know um reconciliation that all
falls into that. By the way, let me just
kind of backtrack just for a second and
and say this. What we've done thus far
is show this.
When a Christian is forgiven of their
sins as spoken of in the scripture, you
are forgiven of all your sins. Period.
There is no scripture teaching that
says, "Well, as a Christian, you're
forgiven for your sins up to this point
in time, but after that, uh, you're not
forgiven of your sins and you must do
this or you're in danger of what happens
in the final judgment if you don't
repent for them, which is, you know, 7th
day Adventist theology." Now, this
concept of this partial forgiveness of
sins, ignoring the totality of sins,
again, if you're going to be an
Adventist and and you want to refute
what we said, refute for me the Greek in
1 John 1:7 because it says that he
forgave us of all sin. And you saw the
word all and all is totality. All is
all. Um, so anyway, that concept doesn't
exist of this partial forgiveness. Well,
and it's also important too, Jim,
because people are going to take
objection to, for example, to 1 John 18.
I just had a guy email me last week,
actually, who was like, well, first John
18, he's talking about the Gnostics in
the book of First John. And I I said, I
I agree with that, but that doesn't mean
the application is not still valid to
the fact that John is writing to
believers. This is an epistle. It's not
written to to just out into the ether,
you know, to some ethereal, you know,
whoever. It's written to believers, a
group of believers. And he writes to
believers, and says, "If you say you
have no sin, you're a liar. You're
deceiving yourself." Which is why again,
you need to take the posture daily,
Lord, forgive me. I know that I fall
short. It doesn't mean that you're
consciously just at every moment like,
"Oh, I can just live however I want. I
just The new birth has to do with
desires." It it's being made a new
creature is a a deep concept. But I say
all that just to say again, I I know
where the Adventist mindset is going to
come or or where they're what they're
going to sort of be thinking when they
hear these things. And I want to make
sure that they they understand you
correctly. Um did you have anything else
you wanted to add there before I um say
my I'll stop. I mean we could just I
could keep going and stuff but so yeah.
So well with regards to reconciliation
Yeah. Isaiah. Isaiah who we will look at
momentarily.
He says that our sins are what have
separated us from God. That's Isaiah
59:2.
Our sins are what have separated us from
God. Which means that well, like I just
said, sin is what has separated a person
from God. And when a person accepts
Christ by faith, they're reconciled to
God. Romans 5 1-9 or 1 through 11, I
guess, technically. Yeah. We looked at
Go ahead. Let me show Colossians chapter
1. Yep. Verses 20 through 22. Cool.
We're reconcil. Yeah. Okay. Good. I
mean, because it it is a it's a great um
set of verses to to bring up.
I'll share that.
When you you see what's underlined here
in front of you in verse 20, reconcile
this is Christ all things to himself.
The word reconcile in in verse 20 is the
same word in 22.
Same word reconcile
122. He Christ has now reconciled in his
body of flesh by his death. In other
words, us in order to present you holy
and blameless are reproached before him.
Look at the words he has now.
That those set of words have a distinct
meaning. He He has now. That word, the
one I'm circling around here with it
looks like a V and a U and a V. That's
the word for has now. And it means what?
A point of time simultaneous with the
event of the discourse itself or now.
An event, a point of time simultaneous
with the discourse. And what is the
discourse in this case? The discourse is
you're being reconciled in the body of
Christ. Now, so this is an event
happening now, not later, but now. But
reconciliation itself means this in the
Greek, it's to establish a proper
friendly interpersonal relations after
they've been disrupted or broken. And in
our case, you can see underline here in
Colossians 1:20, the same word, through
him, God reconciled the whole world to
himself. When you combine what reconcile
means is is to make right something that
was broken. And when did he do it? He
did it now. He didn't do it or promised
to do it later. He doing it now. So
reconcile is to bring back to repair a
relationship something that was broken.
Like I want to reconcile a friendship.
Well then I got to go talk to the
friend. We reunion. Now, God has
reconciled us to him through Christ. And
he did it. And as 122 says, now, not
later. You have been reconciled. You're
not waiting for it. And that's perfect,
Jim, because that's exactly where where
I was going at there with Romans 5 1-9
is that by faith that happens.
Therefore, having been justified by
faith, we have peace with God.
Right now, I have peace with God. Not
because of anything in myself, not
because I measure up to some certain
standard, but Christ does. And by being,
again, this gets back, folks. You're
going to hear me beat this drum until
your ears bleed, I guess. But hopefully
it'll be bleeding to the the sound of
angels because it's just a glorious
reality. Union with Christ. If you're a
former Adventist, study union with
Christ. That will blow the lid off.
you'll understand why Adventism is a
false gospel. They have that
organization cannot bring you peace. It
cannot bring you reconciliation like
we're talking about union with Christ.
But this means that believers sins no
longer separate them from God. That's
what reconciliation is. Otherwise, they
don't have peace. They have enmity
because Isaiah said it's our sins that
are separating us from God. So, if I'm
united now to Christ, I'm no longer
separated from God. that means my sin's
not there anymore. As we're going to see
tonight, that's not possible in the
system in Adventism. They may say that.
They may pay lip service to that, the
organization, as we're going to see as
well tonight, that there's a lot of
double speak going on, cognitive
dissonance,
but they can't honestly say that because
at the end of the day, you don't know if
your names come up in the investigative
judgment, and you don't know if you
passed. It's still in limbo. It's a
divine grand to be determined. You don't
know yet. Yet, that's not the way the
Apostle Paul talked about it. So, since
believers are presently reconciled to
God, that means sin has been put away at
Calvary. This goes back to what we were
saying initially in that first question.
Atonement centers around the burial, the
the life, death, burial, and
resurrection of Jesus Christ.
That is what atonement centers on,
folks. It is all about the death,
burial, and resurrection of the Lord
Jesus Christ.
in conjunction with Christ sacrifice
being propitiatory. Right? We've shown
examples tonight. You've seen them on
the screen. What propitiation means,
what reconciliation means, what
justification means, and what it means
to the believer in Christ. And it means
you have been all of those
justified, reconciled, redeemed
immediately with faith in Christ. Yes.
And for the Adventist to get that
through their head, I know it's going to
be hard. I I I know it's like a
roadblock for them, but this is what the
scriptures teach.
You know, in Adventism, you're going to
find, you know, your doctrine, but this
is what the scriptures teach.
I want to, this is just from the
article, folks, on our website of union
with Christ. Um this is just a sampling
of some of the promises
that one receives upon entering into
Christ. So when you see throughout
scripture it is repeat over 200 times in
the New Testament. 200 times in the New
Testament phrases of in Christ in Christ
Jesus in him. These are things you just
read over and you think oh poetics and
it's just the way they wrote. No, the
author is saying something very deep
when he says these these things which is
ultimately the Holy Spirit
union with Christ.
These are the promises that one receives
upon entering into Christ. Not after an
investigative judgment,
not after 1844. And don't tell me
Adventists, oh this is Calvinism. No,
this is the Bible.
This is the Bible. I'm just telling you
what the scriptures are saying. If you
want to call that Calvinism, by all
means do it. That's exactly why I'm a
Calvinist. Jim's not, by the way. So,
you can quit using that excuse that what
we're saying tonight, oh, that's because
of Calvinism. No, Jim's not a Calvinist.
We're talking about something far more
fundamental here, far more transcendent
than systematic theology. Notice what it
says.
All of the things one receives by being
in Christ, they're dead to sin,
justified, forgiven, redeemed, freedom
from condemnation, made part of the body
of Christ, holy and blameless, chosen,
adopted, sealed with the Holy Spirit,
recipients of grace, made spiritually
alive, consecrated, anointed, new
creatures, reconciled,
seated with Christ in heaven. There's a
now and a not yet component to this. A
down payment of the spirit being the
seal. The promise that even though I'm
not physically there yet, one day I will
be because God's given me the spirit as
a promise that I will be there in God's
favor, brought near to God, at peace,
complete, promised, resurrection, saved,
called, you have eternal life. Present
tense, present participle in the Greek
in those verses. righteous, established
in the faith, spiritually circumcised,
in the light, pure, and dead to the law.
Jim, can an honest Seventh Day
Adventist, or I should say not
necessarily an honest, but a consistent
Seventh Day Adventist, can a consistent
Seventh Day Adventist claim those
things? No, not at all. They don't. They
don't. I mean, I feel sorry for
Adventists to a certain degree because I
I I know they'll put their happy face
on, but I I mean, I've heard from enough
former Adventists, of course, everybody
everybody knows I've never been in
Adventist, so I I'm not speaking from
that, but I've talked to a lot of former
Adventists, and they're absolutely
tormented by the investigative judgment.
I hear over and over and over because
they have no security. They don't know
what their future holds for them. You've
seen on screen tonight already,
Adventist, what your future holds for
you if you become a Christian. Of
course, we all know Adventist, you're
not a Christian. So, so let's not play
that game. You you you've got a wrong
Jesus. You got a wrong gospel. You got
to get out of this church. But if you
were to become a true Christian,
you would be set free. There would be a
feeling there'd be a freedom that that
you can't even fathom right now.
So true. That that is ultimately
summarized what atonement is about. It's
about being reconciled to God. all of
your sins forgiven, united to Christ
where you receive all of the benefits of
Christ. I could go into a whole thing
tonight, Jim, which I'm not going to do
this now. We're going to move to the
next section. But this then brings into
this shows how theology is connected
because this is what the Lord's Supper
has to do with as well. By the way,
folks, the the visual sign to your
senses of your union with Christ. And
so, all in all, that is what atonement's
about. It's about the death, burial,
resurrection of Christ, being united to
Jesus Christ where you have peace and
you are reconciled to God. And all of
that happens by the death, burial,
resurrection in the person and work of
Jesus. You have to have the right Jesus.
You have to have the correct gospel. If
you're off on either of those things,
you're out. It's not me saying that.
It's not Jim saying that. That's what
the Bible says. I've talked about this
on tons of videos. Jim has as well. But
with that said, brother,
part two briefly here, we're going to
talk about now the atonement being
foretold.
So, not just what is the what is the New
Testament even saying specifically prior
to Christ incarnating, what was pictured
and shown to us and prophesied about
regarding the person and work of Christ.
So, let's read all 12 verses. I want to
read Isaiah 53. Here, let me set this up
for you. Go ahead. You're going to read
I You're going to read what? The first
12 verses. I want Well, it's only 13.
The whole chapter is is 12 12 verses.
So, I'm going to read the I'm going to
read the whole thing because I think
it's important because it is absolutely
important because if we're talking about
probation, investigative judgment in
1844,
then what was prophesied of Christ
before he came in Isaiah ought to be
apparent in Isaiah 53. Yes. Every
Adventist theo the theological concept
and term ought to be present in the
prophecy of the yet and future coming
Christ that you're going to read in
Isaiah 53.
If it's not there Adventist, you got a
problem. So when you read these verses,
especially if you're in Adventist, I
want you to think about probation. I
want you to think about 1844 and the
investigative judgment because we're
going to read verses that are going to
prophesy the suffering servant, the
future and coming Christ. And I'm just
going to spoiler alert, you're not going
to see your theology there.
So anyway, yeah, please, please read
those. This a great this is absolute
where we have to start in a prophecy
about Christ.
All right. So I'm going to read all 12
verses. It's only 12 verses, but notice
what and this is just one place, Jim. We
could go to the psalter. We could go to
Jeremiah. We could go a number of
places, but I'm going to read all 12
verses here. says, "Who has believed
what he has heard from us? And to whom
has the arm of the Lord been revealed?
For he grew up before like a young plant
and like a root out of the dry ground."
Who's the he, Jim? We're talking about
Christ. That's correct. This is a
prophecy about Christ. He had no form or
majesty that we should look at him. He
looked like any ordinary human being.
Yet he was not any ordinary human being
and no beauty that we should desire him.
He looked like an ordinary person.
He was despised and rejected by men, a
man of sorrows and acquainted with
grief. He experienced.
So now sounds like we're getting into
classical Christian creeds talking about
just
he was like us in he was 100% man here.
Looked like us. He experienced life like
we do, yet was without sin. And as one
from whom men hide their faces, he was
despised and we esteemed him not.
Surely he has borne our griefs. This is
a key verse, Jim. And he carried our
sorrows. Yet we esteemed him stricken,
smitten by God, and afflicted. Smitten
by who, Jim?
Smitten by God. Smitten by God. But he
was pierced for our transgressions. Why
was he pierced?
For whose transgressions? He was pierced
for our transgressions.
Humans. Human. That's right. He was
crushed for whose iniquities, Jim? Ours.
Our sins. Our iniquities. Humans. Upon
him was the chastisement that brought us
peace. What brings about peace, Jim?
When sin is expated.
That's right. We're going to talk about
experation later. and with his wounds we
are healed. We like sheep have gone
astray. We have turned everyone to his
own way. This Paul quotes this in
Romans. And to the Lord and the Lord has
laid on him the iniquity of who? Jim.
I'm sorry. I've got I got a small text
here. No, no, you're good. The Lord has
laid on him the iniquity of us all.
Again, us humans. He bore the sin of
humans.
He was oppressed and he was afflicted,
yet he opened not his mouth. Like a lamb
that was led to the slaughter and like a
sheep that bore its shears as silence.
So he opened not his mouth. By
oppression and judgment he was taken
away. And as for his generation who
considered that he was cut off out of
the land of the living, stricken for the
transgressions of my people. Again, my
people humans.
And they made his grave with the wicked.
He had a tomb just like any other
person. and with a rich man in his
death, which he was buried in a rich
man's plot. Although he had done no
violence, there was no deceit in his
mouth. He wasn't a sinner, yet it was
the will of the Lord, Yahweh,
the Almighty, to crush him. Who who
crushed him, Jim? That's right. It's the
will of the Lord. And who did the
crushing?
Well, you're right. God used instruments
to do the crushing, but it was the will
of the Lord. Correct. Yep. Acts chapter
4. He has put him to grief when his soul
makes an offering for guilt. This is a
huge component which I'm going to talk
about some tonight as well. I know I've
said that a lot as as you can see.
Folks, buckle up. He shall see his
offspring. He shall prolong his days.
The will of the Lord shall prosper in
his hand. Out of the anguish of his
soul, he shall see and be satisfied. By
his knowledge shall the righteous one,
my servant, make many to be accounted
righteous. What you were just talking
about, Jim, we don't have a
righteousness in and of ourselves or
accounted righteous on behalf of the
Lord's servant.
And he shall again bear their
iniquities.
Therefore, I will divide him a portion
with the many. And he shall divide the
spoil with the strong. Because he poured
out his soul to death, and was numbered
with the transgressors. Yet he bore the
sin of many again for the fourth time.
He bore the sins of the many, and makes
intercession for transgressions. So you
already answered the initial question.
The father was pleased to crush him, and
we considered him punished by God,
stricken by him, and afflicted. Verse
four, God laid on him the iniquity of us
all
will bear their iniquities. Verses 6 11
and 12. This is the same as 1 Peter
2:14.
In him he bore or or rather in his body
he bore our sin on the cross. Right.
That's so it's so key. He bore our sin.
Yes. Again, there is no 7th day
Adventist theology in anything you just
read. Yeah. about a suffering servant
who's going to bury your sin up to a
certain point in time and then you got
to do your repentance for the rest of
probation. That's just not there.
Not there in the prophecy of Christ.
He also mentioned the guilt offering.
This is a key component because I'm
going to talk about this a little bit
later.
Christ was all of the laws, sacrifices,
and offerings in one. The Adventist
understanding of the ceremonial law is
so far off base. Oh, the ceremonial law
was only to deal with the sins and the
the moral laws. No, folks, all of the
law pointed to to Jesus. That includes
the guilt offering, the sin offering,
the free will offering, the all of the
offerings and and sacrifices. He's all
of them in one. So here Isaiah mentions
Christ will be the one that is
essentially the guilt offering. the
guilt offering. Leviticus 5:14 through
or or 5:14 um through chapter 6 to
somewhere focuses on another aspect of
sin's effects, which is the need for
payment.
So, this is important when we're talking
about this because Jim, they don't they
don't see it that way. We're not going
to necessarily get into like penality
tonight. Um but again, they don't
believe in like a penal substitution.
They believe in just substitution, which
we'll get into some as well tonight. But
forgiveness was dependent upon the
worshipper in Leviticus making amends.
It wasn't just the sacrifice and the
sacrificial animal was viewed as a
restitution.
So the idea is that it's not just enough
to be forgiven. Things have to also be
made right. There's all these different
things that like it it encompasses more
than just paying the penalty of death.
That's how the Adventist views Christ's
death on the cross. Oh, he was just
making payment because the wages of sin
is death. No, folks, there is a a lot
more going on than just that. The debt
that we owe to God and those we've
sinned against, others as well, our
neighbor, is greater than we can pay.
Therefore, God sent his son to not only
be our perfect burnt offering and sin
offering, but also our perfect guilt
offering. The word used for offering of
guilt, Jim, is the exact same word
that's used in Leviticus 5:15 to
describe the compensation or guilt
offering made by the ancient worshipper.
So Jesus paid our debt and now we must
forgive as we have been forgiven. So
Jesus tells us in the Lord's prayer, you
ask for forgiveness as we have forgiven
those who have sinned against us. Some
people will say, see that's that means
your forgiveness is conditional upon you
forgiving others. That's not what the
Lord's saying. He's modeling it after
what we've just seen here. Because
you've been forgiven, you should extend
that to others. You have been forgiven,
which is a key aspect to that. That was
this the same way in Leviticus 5, you
had been forgiven at that point. So,
Adventist theology has no concept of
Jesus being the fulfillment of all the
laws, sacrifices, and offerings. He was
the true burnt offering, which we'll
look at in a moment, the true guilt
offering, sin offering, free will
offering, fragrant offering, etc. There
is an um there's only an understanding
of him being the sin offering or only
paying for sin like I said which is
death. Yet his sacrifice is so much more
in one single sacrifice. So Isaiah here
told us that Jesus is the true guilt
offering and makes things right between
the sinner and God. That's what the
guilt offering did. Restitution. So
Christ's death, burial, and resurrection
was more than merely the sin offering.
Now my second thing, Jim, unless you
have something to tack on to that, I
want to move to one specific piece of
typology before we move to the um second
uh or rather third part of our
discussion here in looking at the
specifics of the Adventist teaching.
Now, we can move on, but I just still
want to hammer that point. The prophecy
of the future and coming Messiah in
Isaiah 53 contains no Adventist
theology.
None.
And matter of fact, what it does do in
Isaiah 53 and show the forgiveness that
we've shown that is taught in First
John, for example. Um, so anyway, yeah,
we can we can move on. I just make the
point the scriptures do not support
Adventist theology. Yes. So, I want to
read folks again. I know that it's it's
reading we're doing more if you're an
Adventist, we're going to read more than
single verses here. We're going to look
at we're going to look at passages,
whole whole passages, not just proof
texts here and there, because we need to
see the whole of what's being said. So,
we're going to read 19 verses here. I
want to read one example of the
atonement being pictured typologically.
And then when we move after this into
the next part, the final part, you're
going to see, folks, why we're really
emphasizing and hammering this. If you
do not know Adventist theology, you're
going to understand why we're bringing
this up and emphasizing this so hard
right now. because buckle up. So I'm
going to read 19 verses here and then
we're going to debrief. So he says
this is talking about Abraham and Isaac
after these things God tested Abraham
and said to him Abraham and he said here
I am taking the posture of the ser of a
servant he said take your son your only
son Isaac whom you love and go to the
land of Mariah and offer him there as a
burnt offering. So we see that there's
an aspect of a burnt offering here on
one of the mountains of which I shall
tell you. So Abraham rose early in the
morning, saddled his donkey and took two
of his young men with him and his son
Isaac. So he took a crew of people and
he cut the wood for the burnt offering
and arose and went to the place of which
God had told him. Imagine that, Jim,
during this this process. He's cutting
wood thinking, I'm about to go sacrifice
my son. Well, there's a lot of of of
backstory here actually because we get
insight into this in Hebrews chapter 11
as to what what Abraham actually
believed. And we're going to see that
here in a second. But I just think about
that how crazy that is being a father
thinking while you're cutting the wood,
you have time to be meditating upon what
you're about to do. On the third day,
notice the third day.
You think that's by happen stance,
folks? You think the Holy Spirit, the
leading of God in in this and and
knowing that it's going to be inscribed
and scripturated as as as apostolic
essentially deposit into into the holy
rit. No. On the third day, Abraham
lifted up his eyes and saw the place
from afar. Then Abraham said to his
young men, "Stay here with the donkey. I
and the boy will go over there and
worship and come again to you." Jim,
notice that people read over this and
don't understand what's being said.
Abraham went out with his men and a
donkey and his son. He said, "Hey, halt.
Me and the boy are going to go worship.
We'll be back." But wait, he's about to
go sacrifice a Isaac. Right?
That shows which the author of Hebrews
tells us in Hebrews 11, Abraham knew if
he had to go through with this, God will
has the power to resurrect him. He'll be
coming back.
And Abraham took the wood of the burnt
offering and laid it on Isaac his son.
So the son carries the wood.
And he took in his hand the fire and the
knife. The father did. So they went both
of them together. And Isaac said to his
father, Abraham, my father. And he said,
here I am, my son. He said, "Behold the
fire and the wood, but where's the lamb
for a burnt offering?"
Abraham said, "God will provide for
himself the lamb for a burnt offering,
my son."
So they went both of them together. When
they came to the place of which God had
told them, Abraham built the altar there
and laid the wood in order and bound
Isaac his son. Notice the father's
actions in this, Jim. Mhm. The father's
involvement
bound Isaac his son and laid him on the
altar on top of the wood. Then Abraham
reached out his hand and took the knife
to slaughter his son. But the angel of
the Lord, we could get caught up on this
and do a whole stream on it. Oh yeah.
Called to him from heaven and
said,"Abraham, Abraham." And he said,
"Here I am, the pre-incarnate Christ."
He said, "Do not lay your hand on the
boy or do anything to him. For now I
know that you fear God. Seeing you have
not withheld your son, your only son,
from me, your only son.
And Abraham lifted up his eyes and
looked. And behold, behind him was a ram
caught in the thicket by his horns.
What's a thicket, Jim?
Oh, it's um it's going to be like brush.
A thorn bush. Yeah.
And Abraham went and took the ram and
offered it up as a burnt offering
instead a substitute of his son. So
Abraham called the name of that place,
the Lord will provide.
And it is said to this day on the mount
of the Lord, it shall be provided. And
the angel of the Lord called to Abraham
a second time from heaven and said, "By
myself I have sworn, declares the Lord."
The angel of the Lord speaks declaring
as the Lord the Almighty, "Because
you've done this and have not withheld
your son, your only son, I will surely
bless you, and I will surely multiply
your offspring as the stars of heaven
and as the sand of the seashore, and
your offspring shall possess the gate of
his enemies. And in your offspring shall
all the nations of the earth be blessed
because you've obeyed my voice." So
Abraham returned to his young men, and
they arose and went together to with uh
went together to Beersa or Bershea. and
Abraham lived at Beer Sheeba. So, what
was my point in bringing all that up or
reading that whole thing? Notice the
parallel, folks. That is a picture of
the atonement of Jesus Christ. He's the
substitute. He's the ram that's caught
in the thicket, a thorn bush on its
head. The father leading his only son up
the mountain carrying the wood for his
own sacrifice to be a sacrifice as a
substitute provided
burnt offering. Verse two, Jesus was
more than just the sin offering. He was
the fulfillment of all the laws,
sacrifices and offerings. We see this
over and over and over in the New
Testament. But again, the emphasis I
want to to point to there is the father
and the son's involvement in the action
and who it is for. Okay? Because what
we're going to move to now, Jim, is part
three, which is
Adventist atonement.
And what we're going to see now, or what
I want to do, is I want to talk about
the
contrast now. Okay?
And I want people to see why we're
making such a a big deal about this. So,
first let's read fundamental belief
number 24 in total, followed by some
claims from their fundamental beliefs
book, which expounds upon it. But before
we get to that, we'll read the
fundamental belief and then I'll uh I'll
have a question for you, Jim, that I
want to hear. So yeah, it says initially
there is a sanctuary in heaven, the true
tabernacle that the Lord set up and not
humans. In it, Christ ministers on our
behalf, making available to believers
the benefits of his atoning sacrifice
offered up once for all on the cross.
At his ascension, he was inaugurated as
our great high priest and began his
intercessory ministry which was typified
by the work of the high priest in the
holy place of the earthly sanctuary.
In 1844 at the end of the prophetic
period of 2300 days, he entered the
second and last phase of his atoning
ministry which was typified by the work
of the high priest in the most holy
place of the earthly sanctuary.
It is a work of investigative judgment
which is part of the ultimate
disposition of all sin typified by the
cleansing of the ancient Hebrew
sanctuary on the day of atonement.
In that typical service, the sanctuary
was cleansed with the blood of animal
sacrifices. But the heavenly things are
purified with the perfect sacrifice
single or singular of the blood of
Jesus. The investigative judgment
reveals to heavenly intelligences who
among the dead are asleep in Christ and
therefore in him are deemed worthy to
have part in the first resurrection.
It also makes manifest who among the
living are abiding in Christ, keeping
the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus,
and in him therefore are ready for
translation into his everlasting
kingdom. This judgment vindicates the
justice of God in saving those who
believe in Jesus. It declares that those
who have remained loyal to God shall
receive the kingdom. The completion of
this ministry of Christ will mark the
close of human probation before the
second advent.
So before we start diving into this more
closely right off the bat, what issues
stick out to you? You speak to the
audience. I'm going to use the restroom
real quick. All right. Um, I mean this
this whole section here is just an utter
theological disaster. I mean just I
would look I'm as as Miles was reading
I'm I'm looking at the the first
paragraph and it's talking about Christ
and it say it says atoning sacrifice
offered once and for all that they're
going to get the benefits of this
doesn't say that Christ atonement is a
completed and finished act. you're going
to get whatever it means in Adventism by
the benefits of this atonement. Uh we're
going to have more to say on that. And
then it goes on to talk about he's
inaugurated as our high priest. I see
this in Adventist literature all the
time. High priest. What Adventists don't
realize high priest is a title. It's not
a priesthood.
You can be a high priest in the Masonic
order, in Islam, in Wikah,
in Judaism. you can be a high priest,
but it's not the order. So, whenever
Adventists use the word high priest,
they always mean a Levitical high priest
when they speak of Christ, which is
wrong. And I hope we we'll probably get
into that. But the key phrase, I think,
in here to the topic we're we're
discussing. I'm going to read again from
it. He entered the second and last phase
of his atoning ministry.
The Bible speaks of no two-phaseed
atoning ministry for Christ. You already
saw in Isaiah 53, it speaks of what
Christ will do, this suffering servant
when he comes. We saw in the New
Testament, Christ came and what
happened? He is the propitiation of our
sins. He is the reconciliation. He is
the one who redeemed.
We saw fulfilled in the New Testament
what was prophesied in the old in Isaiah
53. But here, this second and last
phase, there's no two-phased atonement.
But in Adventism, you have a twofphase
atonement. This is probably the most
egregious thing I think in in this
entire paragraph. There's many other
egregious, but I think this is by far
the most. What do you think, Miles?
Yeah. Well, I've got three things.
There's there's a lot I could camp out
on this again the whole night, folks.
I'm going to be making videos on this
specific thing here coming up because
well on each each three of these these
points here. Um so three things I want
to point out here that I have or take
major umbrage with scripturally the the
very first sentence. So they proof text
Hebrews 8 1-2 at the beginning to try
and support the idea of a building in
heaven that Jesus entered but only the
holy place outer apartment of that. Um
this is a super common Adventist claim.
You're going to hear that constant.
they're going to be advocating for this
physical building and he entered the
first apartment in 1844 moved to the
second apartment and then you'll get the
the Roy Gaines of the world or the
people who have read Roy Gain that try
and say well it was more symbolic
there's not an actual curtain and it's
wrong one big room and there's a throne
with wheels and all this sort of thing
but they conveniently ignore that the
author expounds upon this if you keep
reading through to chapter 9 the true
tabernacle that God set up and not man
mentioned in 8 1-2 who is the one that
was not made with hands in 9:24.
And what does it say, Jim? For Christ
has entered not into holy places made
with hands, which are copies of the true
things, but into heaven itself
now to appear in the presence of God on
our behalf. God's presence permeates all
of heaven. It's not contained to an
apartment like it was on earth. That was
a type and a shadow. They're taking a
type and a shadow and think that because
it uses the term copies, it's therefore
identical except what was on earth was a
scale model. No, he entered into heaven
itself. That's the most holy place. He
didn't enter there in 1844, but at his
had his ascension. When it says that
they are copies, the SDA church, like I
said, takes this hyperliterally, but
only because it's convenient for the
system. They don't do that with
everything else in scripture. only when
they need to try and support this
concept like in Revelation one saying
Jesus is amongst the candlesticks
then they try and claim that this proves
he's in a literal building like the
earthly sanctuary that that has
candlesticks except in the last verse of
of Revelation 1:20 it tells you the
candlesticks are just representative of
churches
so no furthermore they completely ignore
the part of 81 which says that Jesus
entered in and sat down there's no
mention here of when they're quoting
from the same verse. They only quote a
part a portion of the verse, but not the
fact that he's entered in and sat down,
which is huge again throughout this book
because we're talking about the
priesthood and how Jesus is a better
high priest, king, um, prophet, priest,
king, better everything. Everything is
he's he's better. It talks about a
better Moses, a better Joshua, etc. They
completely ignore that part of the
verse. This phrase when understood in
relation to the Levitical priest who
never sat down, it completely demolishes
this doctrine. I mean, absolutely
decimates it. So, of course, they ignore
that part of the verse. What's being
said is Jesus entered into heaven
itself, which is the antitype that the
earthly was only a shadow and picture
of, and sat down on his throne after
completing the work of dealing with sin.
Which leads me to my next problem. They
say upon his ascension, he was
inaugurated as a high priest. You kind
of talked on this a little bit, Jim.
This explains why they don't see the
work in Jesus's life, death, burial, and
resurrection as sufficient for dealing
with sin because there has to be some
second phase later on.
No, this is false. This is completely
false. This is coming from Ellen White
in the great controversy. Page 420, she
says, "After his ascension, our our
savior began his work as our high
priest." No, Christ functioned as a
priest in his once offering up of
himself as a sacrifice, satisfying
divine justice, reconciling us to God,
then making in a continual intercession
for us as a priest, king. No mention of
king in this entire chapter. Nothing
about the kingly role of Christ.
They don't have Jesus functioning as a
priest through his life, though. How do
we know this? How do we know that Christ
actually did this? Well, Hebrews 26
and 17. Hebrews 26-1 17. Jim, can you
read that for us?
Says, "For surely it is not angels that
he helped, but he helped the offspring
of Abraham." Halt. Oh, sorry. Two. Yeah.
Halt. We were just there where God
promised about the offspring of Abraham.
Do you see the connection, folks?
He helps the offspring of Abraham,
humans again. Right. Continue, Jim.
Therefore, he had to be made like his
brothers in every respect so that he
might become a merciful and faithful
high priest in the service of God to
make propitiation for the sins of the
people. So, like we looked at earlier
regarding propitiation,
Christ's sacrifice was propitiatory.
That's what we were told from scripture,
right, Jim? That's it. That's before the
ascension
in his life here on earth. More
specifically, his death, burial, and
resurrection. That means he had to be a
high priest in his life, not at the
ascension.
His ascension was his inauguration and
coronation to be a king, to take his
throne, which the author tells us in
Hebrews 8 and 10, where he'll be seated
in in Psalm 110, which is a prophecy
about him.
And he mentions this Psalm 110 in
Hebrews 1 as well to talk about Jesus
taking the throne. Again, the the
sitting down aspect which is so key to
this whole thing. Christ functioned as a
high priest in his life, death, burial,
and resurrection. The work of the priest
was to deal with sin. But he's not a
Levitical ironic priest wearing
Levitical priesthood garb up in heaven
like Ellen White said with the bells on
his him.
Yeah, because he could totally
potentially die and his body needs
pulled out, right? It it just No, it
wasn't at his ascension. They also fail
fail to recognize the the fundamental
key of Jesus's ascension. I know I
mentioned this earlier, but that was
about him being coronated as King of
Kings and Lord of Lords in our family
worship. Right now, we're we just
finished the book of Luke today. Now,
we're moving to what I call Luke 2, aka
the book of Acts. And at the end of
Luke, he talks about the ascension. And
I was reminded of how the Christian
church has so I'm not saying completely
forgotten, but we, you know, we
celebrate the birth of our Lord. We
celebrate the death of our Lord. We need
to take also some some
reminders from the ascension of our Lord
and how he told the apostles, "It's
better that I leave than to stay." And
there's a reason for that because him
being on the throne is part of the good
news. Christ has conquered death, sin,
the grave, Satan, etc. But nevertheless,
he was not he didn't ascend to be
inaugurated as a high priest, but as a
high priest king to take his rightful
throne to rule and reign until all of
his enemies are made a foottool. Not to
work with in not to work on dealing with
sin in a building in heaven. It totally
misses the boat here. But then three,
the final thing
they said the heavenly things are
purified with the perfect sacrifice of
the blood of Christ.
Sacrifice singular.
They've twisted Hebrews 9:23, folks.
They twisted Hebrews 9:23 here
because Hebrews 9:23 does not say
singular.
It's plural and it's small, but this is
crucial. It impacts their entire
understanding.
I mentioned this earlier
that Christ is all of the laws,
sacrifices,
and offerings plural. Hebrews 9:23 says,
"Thus it was necessary for the copies of
the heavenly things to be purified with
these rights, but the heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices
than these."
Christ's sacrifice encompassed all of
the laws, sacrifices, and offerings in
one. And it wasn't for him to then go to
heaven afterward to begin some cleansing
of a sanctuary 1811 years after his
ascension to then begin. No, it was the
single sacrifice of Christ at Calvary
that this happened. You quoted
Colossians 1:20 earlier, Jim, which
we're going to look at again in a little
bit, and it says that that happened at
the cross. He did this work by the
cross. the death, burial, resurrection
of Christ, not well that he just paid
the penalty there and then well off into
the future somewhere. There's going to
be some second phase where he continues
this sort of thing. Even though it says
he's seated on the throne, which the
Levitical priest was never set sitting
on the throne because the work was never
finished. He's on his throne and we're
in him and we can be seated in the
heavenly places with him, but there's
going to be some second phase where our
sin is still being dealt with. They use
the term in here all throughout. In him,
in him, these terms of union with
Christ. They can't consistently say that
in accordance with scripture. If your
sin's still being dealt with, you're
still at enmity with God. Isaiah says
it's your sin that separates you from
God. If your sin is still something
that's being dealt with, folks, you
don't have access into the most holy
place. those who are in Christ according
to Hebrews 69 19 or 19-20 the the verses
of this ministry
we have this as a sure and steadfast
anchor of the soul that holds behind the
veil that has gone behind the veil after
the order of MelkiseDC
we know that's the second veil contrary
to what Ellen White falsely claimed oh
no that's just the first veil between
the courtyard and the holy place no it's
not because it says he entered the veil
that's that's in reference there after
the order of MelkiseDC who was a high
priest. It was the curtain that only the
high priest could go behind the most
holy place.
You can't have that if your sin's still
being dealt with. But he says like I
like I mentioned earlier, sacrifices
plural. And that is a key thing that
they blunder here because the scapegoat
was a part of the laws sacrifices and
offerings.
They are then ascribing, we're going to
look at a little bit later, one of the
aspects of Christ's work to the devil,
which means Jesus didn't fulfill all of
the laws, sacrifices, and offerings. He
fulfilled all of them except one in
their minds. Even though most of them,
when you ask them, "Well, was Jesus the
burnt offering?" I I've asked Adventists
this, they it looks like their brain
short circuit. They they don't they're
like, "Uh, I hadn't really thought about
this." Well, when you understand that
Christ is all the laws, sacrifices, and
offerings, then when you hear this idea
of the scapegoat being Satan, then you
realize why Christians when they hear
this go what? No. But furthermore, like
you mentioned earlier, Jim, in
conjunction with Colossians 1:20, for in
him all the fullness of God was pleased
to dwell, and through him to reconcile
to himself all things, whether on on in
uh whether on earth or in heaven, making
peace,
enmity gone.
Romans 5:1, therefore,
being justified by faith, we have
present tense peace with God, just like
Isaiah told us.
He did that by the blood of his cross at
Calvary. Not a long process that started
in 1844.
But now I want to look at some quotes
expounding upon this belief in the
fundamental beliefs book which comes
from the fundamental beliefs book
itself. Notice what they say here and
then I'll have a question for you. Okay.
Okay.
So he said or it says the sacrifices of
the earthly sanctuary were repetitive
like a story. This ritual parable of
redemption was told and retold year
after year. By contrast, the antitype,
the actual atoning death of our Lord,
it's a key phrase, not atonement,
atoning death, took place at Calvary
once for all time. Hebrews 6 or Hebrews
9:26-28 and 10:10-14.
On the cross, the penalty for human sin
was fully paid. Divine justice was
satisfied. From a legal perspective, the
world was restored to favor with God.
Romans 5:18. The atonement or
reconciliation
was completed on the cross as
foreshadowed by the sacrifices and the
penitent believer can trust in the
finished work of our Lord. Close close
quote. Now, Jim, you're going to get
SDAs that this is what they're going to
point to. We believe atonement was
completed at the cross. But as we're
going to see in a moment, folks, as
we're going to see in a moment, they
teach that no sins were canceled at
Calvary. That's by their their own
prophetus and pioneers. Yet in the
fundamental belief book here, they claim
that reconciliation was completed on the
cross. How does that work, Jim? No sins
can the cross yet reconciliation
happened there. Yeah, it doesn't. This
is just, you know, when I read stuff
like this, it's easy for me to see how a
Christian could read this and say,
"Well, yeah, the Seventh Day Adventist,
I I see, you know, it looks pretty
Christian-like." And um but like you, I
know what they really say, and I know
the some of the other quotes. And and
I'm just going to have to say these are
not true 7th Day Adventist beliefs.
These are put there to I I think almost
to asscience of some 7th Day Adventists.
I find 7th Day Adventists when I
dialogue them online and I just flat out
say, you know, your Christ did not die
on the cross for sins. They're they're
almost shocked to a certain degree
because they know that that just sounds
horrible. And I go, yeah, it does sound
horrible because it is horrible. Yeah.
But that's what your your sear and your
founders taught. So, I think Adventists
like reading what you just read because
I think it makes them feel good. But
when they see these other quotes, it it
I think it's going to shock them in into
reality because that's what Adventism
really believes. Yeah. And I don't care
what their fundamental belief book says
at the end of the day. If they're
inspired supposed divinely inspired
prophetist who corrects inaccurate
interpretations of scripture, she's the
highest authority. So, what she says
stands. That's what they'll refer to as
light. I was watching back not too long
ago the uh I actually streamed it on my
channel, the uh the discussion with
Walter Martin and William Johnson. Yeah.
And there's a there's a phrase he says
in there that if you're not SDA, you're
not going to pick up on. You're going to
think, oh, he's just using like, you
know, Christianes sounding language,
etc. But no, it's something very
specific. He tells Walter Martin that
the reason they rejected Dez Ford's
interpretations is because they didn't
see light in them. Aka, they didn't
align with Ellen White's writings.
That's what's being said there. We
looked at it against Ellen White's
writings. Nope, it didn't align. So,
it's out. That's the way she functions.
There's no way that they can actually
say what they're saying here and still
uphold the statement of confidence in
the writings of LG White. It is not
possible. It's called double speak.
There's cognitive dissonance going on
here. So, like you said, this is going
to be here um to appease, you know, and
and sound Christian, but then over here,
you're going to have this other thing
going on that completely contradicts
that. But, oh well. So, since sin is
transferred to heaven in their system by
means of Jesus's blood, which we're
going to see, how are they then dealt
with at the cross?
So this is when they go on to describe
the first apartment ministry of Christ
because if that's the question you're
asking, well then they go on to expound
upon this. So what was Christ doing from
his ascension until October 22nd, 1844?
Because that's what a person's then
going to ask when they're hearing about
this 1844. Well, what was he doing until
then? For 1811 years or whatever it is.
So he they claim he was doing what was
called the daily ministry of the
priests. So here's what the fundamental
beliefs book claims. And then we'll look
at what Ellen White uh uh said
essentially which is what they're
pulling from here. So it says
the priestly ministry in the holy place
of the sanctuary could be characterized
as a ministry of intercession,
forgiveness, reconciliation, and
restoration. So halt. They just said
reconciliation happened at the cross.
Well, now they're saying it happened in
the daily ministration here, which is
what they claimed Christ was doing until
1844.
Reconciliation, folks, is not this long
drawn out thing that God,
it's just it's missing it. But anyway,
they continue, a continual ministry
provide uh it provided constant access
to God through the priest. It symbolized
the truth that the repentant sinner has
immediate and constant access to God
through Christ's priestly ministry as
intercessor and mediator. There's their
proof text. When the penitent sinner
came to the sanctuary with a sacrifice,
he laid his hand on the head of the
innocent animal and confessed his sins.
Now, get this, folks. If you're a former
Adventist, this is what you need to
grasp. This is where we go off the
rails. This act symbolically transferred
his sin and its penalty to the victim.
As a result, he obtained forgiveness of
sins. Close quote. So atonement wasn't
actually completed at the cross like
they said in that earlier quote because
reconciliation was happening during this
outer apartment holy place ministry.
That issue aside, this is key to their
whole sanctuary model right here. This
is what they claim supposedly happens
today. A person confesses their sins.
They're symbolically transferred to
heaven by means of Jesus's blood into
the sanctuary to then be dealt with.
Here's then what Ellen White or or
here's the Ellen White quote that they
are essentially summarizing this with
which is from Patriarchs and Prophets
page 354.
Quote, "The most important part of the
daily ministration was the service
performed in behalf of individuals." For
who, Jim? Who was the daily ministry?
The daily ministry that the priest
performed, who was it on behalf of? That
was for other individuals. Yes,
individuals. So that's what she says
here as well. So remember that it was
for individuals. The repentant sinner
brought his offering to the door of the
tabernacle and placing his hand upon the
victim's head, confessed his sins, thus
in figure transferring them from himself
to the innocent sacrifice. By his own
hand, the animal was then slain and the
blood was carried by the priest into the
holy place and sprinkled before the
veil. This is her describing the daily
ministration.
So daily bringing an animal, sacrificing
it themselves, the priests would then
take the blood and supposedly bring it
into the holy place to sprinkle it
before the veil behind which was the ark
containing the law and that the sinner
had transgressed. So the the veil
separating the holy from the most holy
place by this ceremony the sin was
through the blood transferred in figure
to the sanctuary. So notice folks, Ellen
White here claims that the most
important part in the daily ministration
of the Levitical priests, which was a
work performed for the individual
Israelites.
The repentant Israelite brought an
animal to sacrifice, confessing their
sins over it, and then killing the
animal. The priest would then carry the
blood into the holy place and sprinkle
it before the altar, transferring it to
the sanctuary. That's the claim. This is
flatout false
for a number of reasons. Hebrews 9:13.
Let me bring it up here so you can just
see it, folks.
Well, I'm going to have to type it in in
this separate window here. Hebrews 9:13.
For those that want to look it up.
Hebrews 9:13.
Okay, let me bring it up here.
Hebrews 9 9:13 says that in the
Levitical system, the sprinkling of the
blood on behalf of the defiled
individual cleansed the flesh.
They were sprinkled them with the ashes
after the burnt offering, etc., and it
cleansed the flesh, but it wasn't
permanent. In contrast to that, Christ's
blood cleanses the conscience. The blood
of the animal did not transfer the sins
of the individual into the sanctuary.
The blood symbolically purified, but
wasn't perfect like Christ blood because
the process had to happen over and over
and over again. But Christ by his single
sacrifice cleanses us inwardly. The
washing of regeneration. Titus 3:5. It's
not something that has to be done over
and over and over again. So the author
is making this compare and contrast. In
both instances, the blood purifies. It
does not transfer. Jesus's sacrifice is
simply better because it brings with it
union with himself, regeneration,
being sealed with the Holy Spirit and
cleansed in conscience, which is why all
of the promises the Bible lists
regarding union with Christ can be
applied to the believer presently.
But secondly, with regards to the
logistics and mechanics of all of this,
Ellen White has twisted the daily
administration work.
So let's read our article now on the
Answering Adventism website really
quick.
I want to read a portion of this here
because I go into this in great detail
talking about this specific quote.
So what does it say here? You can bring
this up yourself, folks. If you want to
look it up, you can type in a portion of
that question, any portion of it, and
see it. There's the question. Did the
high priest carry the blood of the
sacrificed animals into the holy place
each day? That's what she claimed. The
daily ministration for individuals, the
sin was in type transferred to the
sanctuary daily.
That's the claim. Okay.
in patriarchs and prophets right here
as well as elsewhere. She falsely
asserted that during the daily
ministration of the priests in the holy
place, which is the outer apartment, the
blood of the sacrificed animals was
carried by the priest into the holy
place and sprinkled before the veil and
that by this ceremony the sin was
through the blood transferred in figure
to the sanctuary. This contradicts the
Bible where we are told that apart from
the once a year day of atonement
service.
The priest only sprinkled blood before
the veil in the holy place on two
occasions
right here. Leviticus 4 3-12 when a
priest sinned
and two when the entire Israelite
community sinned.
Blood was never taken into the holy
place on a daily basis when one of the
leaders sinned.
Right there,
nor when an individual sinned, she said
it was for the daily ministration.
Ellen White contradicted the Bible by
saying the sins of the individual were
transferred on a daily basis in figure
to the sanctuary through the blood
sacrificed. She's on record in the same
book claiming that whatever contradicts
God's word, we can be sure proceeds from
Satan. But also she claimed that the
words in patriarchs and prophets is are
barricaded by a thus sayeth the lord. We
will let you connect the dots. So all of
that to say this means their type
antitype completely breaks down. Full
stop. Blood was not transferred daily by
the priest for the repentant Israelite
into the holy place to be sprinkled
within the veil. Yet that's what they
claim to try and picture what happens
for the Christian today. You daily
confess and your sin is transferred to
heaven just like with the Israelites.
Except no, that was not what happened
daily. Confession of sin is evidence of
a contrite heart toward God, not about
transference to heaven. Jim, it amazes
me. Adventists are quick to claim,
again, like I said earlier,
that Christians have forgotten about the
priestly work of Christ. I've heard this
probably a thousand times in in in
10 years, you know, yet the entire 24th
chapter of their fundamental belief book
on the sanctuary and the investigative
judgment doesn't mention the kingly role
of Christ one single time. Not a single
time. You know why? Because Jesus being
a high priest king pres uh presently
completely decimates this entire
framework and timeline. Jesus is after
the order of MelkiseDC, not Levi.
MelkiseDC was a high priest king.
Hebrews 7:1, Jesus isn't only a high
priest, but a king. He's a priest king,
which is why we're told again, over and
over and over again in just Hebrews
alone, the book of Acts, Paul, he's
seated. He's seated. He's ruling and
reigning until all of his enemies are
made his foottool. The Levites never did
this. His work of mediation for his
people does not involve blood and
blotting out sins.
But to their claim that Christians have
forgotten about the priestly work of
Christ, which is again the common excuse
they give to try and justify this, I
just tell them they have no concept of
the kingly rule of Christ from his
throne. I go, okay, and you've forgotten
about the kingly rule, the aspect of
Christ. No, we actually are
acknowledging both that Christ
functioned as a priest by dealing with
sin, which is the function of the priest
at Calvary, and then now he's assumed
his role in his exaltation as a priest
king after the order of Mkisedc. You
have him in heaven wearing Levitical
priesthood garments still dealing with
sin where no reconciliation can actually
have happened because your sin is still
standing against you. You know, as I I
was thinking I' I've thought a lot about
this topic of the high Levitical priest
Jesus in Adventism. And I often hear
from Adventists say, "Well, it's just a
type, you know, it's the type. It's it's
not real." And it's like, "Well, wait a
second. your sanctuary, you believe, is
a real physical location.
And and I look I look at your literature
and I I see all the graphical pictures
going back a hundred years of Levitical
priest Jesus, right? Standing in, you
know, in front of the Ten Commandments,
in front of the the mercy seat, the
altar, and and you know what I see is
this? So I see a Levitical priest Jesus
dressed up in pretty fancy robes, fancy
turban. And Adventists like to tell me
that what they think of the atonement,
it's a type of the day of atonement in
Leviticus 16. Then I then I think, did
you read Leviticus 16? Did you read what
the um the Levitical priests were
supposed to wear? It's not what you have
in your pictures. It's just a white
linen robe and a turban and a sash. But
your Jesus is now ignoring the words of
Christ and dresses up in some big fancy
robe.
So Levitical priest Jesus in Adventism
can't even follow the rules and your and
your priest is not a type. You believe
he's real because he's in a real
sanctuary. He's really got Levitical
priest clothes on. And you know in
numbers 18:7 it says this basically it
says that any outsider to the Levitical
priesthood who tries to be a Levitical
priest put him to death.
Adventism you just made you just gave
Christ a death sentence in your whole
atonement
framework by dressing Christ up as a
Levitical priest because Numbers 18:7
says you got an outsider coming into the
Levitical priesthood. Jesus is an
outsider. He's not from Levi. He's from
Judah. put him to death. So, not only
should Jesus be put to death according
to what you've done, you don't even
dress him up right, and I could go on
and on and on with these just errors
that they have thinking that they're
following the Day of Atonement ceremony,
and it's so off in almost every single
place I look. Well, and Jim, it it's
nonsense. You know, I'm not dogging on
the individual SDA. I I remember being
an Adventist. you kind of just
regurgitate the talking points, etc. But
it it's just nonsense to say, "Oh, when
it comes to the garments, like, oh, no,
it's just a type." No, it's not, folks.
Ellen White said at a certain point in
the future, he's going to take those off
and assume his kingly garments. He's not
ruling and reigning yet because they
have no concept of the kingdom of God
being present. And now, we're not going
to get into all that, but it's not just
a type. And to the second point that you
mentioned, that's why he's depicted that
way in all of their second commandment
violations where they have him wearing
this turban and the ephod and all this
stuff before the the you know the ark of
the covenant. Well, it's because that's
based off of the writings of Ellen
White. I just had a friend reach out
today who sent me an ad that he got for
some of course some end times prophecy
seminar that the SDA church is doing and
it's a Levitical priesthood Jesus
standing there wearing the garments etc.
So no it's not just a a a type or you
know the get out of jail free card to
say oh well it's just a type. Well it's
not depicted that way by your
prophetist. It's not depicted that way
in the art and your scholars don't talk
about it that way. So, no, we're told
it's a real sanctuary when you got a
real Jesus up there dressed like this.
And Advent, I would say read Leviticus
16:4 cuz that's what the priest is
supposed to wear in the day of
atonement, not how you dress your Jesus
up, which is a fake Jesus. And not just
that, Jim, but if you read Exodus, God
gives the instructions around the
Levites wearing those garments and that
they're specifically for the Levitical
priesthood garment or or for the the
priest garment. And do you know why? Do
you know what it says about why they're
to wear them? No. What's it say? To be
seen to be seen as holy
Jesus doesn't need to wear those
garments. He's not after the order. He
doesn't need to. It was typological of
Jesus. He's not literally wearing those
garments. Well, now I want to look at
what does Ellen White and the SDA
pioneers claim or a couple of them
happened at the cross. Okay? Because as
we've been mentioning tonight, Jim, we
just read from their fundamental beliefs
book. Atonement we will say and
reconciliation was completed at the
cross. That's what that paragraph from
the previous page said. So now let's see
what Ellen White said about this. Okay.
Patriarchs and Prophets, page 357. I've
quoted this I don't even know how many
times. quote, "The blood of Christ,
while it was to release the repentant
sinner from the condemnation of the law,
was not to cancel the sin,
it would stand on record in the
sanctuary until the final
the final atonement."
So in the type, the blood of the sin
offering removed the sin from the
penitent, but it rested in the sanctuary
until the day of atonement. Close quote.
No,
no. I mean, that's it right there.
That's it right there. No sin was
canceled at the cross. It's scored in
heaven to begin being dealt with in
heaven in 1844. Again, if this is the
case, one cannot say they're actually
reconciled to God. Imagine all the
believers, Jim, from from 33 to 1844 AD,
right? None. all their sins still stood
against them. Right? I've heard
Adventists try and say, "Well, but they
had assurance when they walked away from
the animal that they it was taken care
of even if they still stood against
them." Folks, no. Only the high priest
had access to God. The the whole point
that the author is trying to make in
Hebrews is that we all as a royal
priesthood have access to God now, not
just one person. If your sin still
stands against you, you're not
reconciled. It doesn't matter if you
say, "Oh, well, if you," because they
talk about this in the book, in the
fundamental belie. Just as the
repentant, you know, Israelite, you
know, sacrificed the animal at the door
and walked away after confessing their
sins, knew that it was taken care of, so
it is for the the Christian.
No, you're you're they're completely
completely missing what's being said
there. any comments that you have on
this quote? Well, you know, so so you
just showed us, I mean, to me, it's the
premier quote because it comes from
Ellen White and and like I tell
Adventist, you know, she's chapter 18 of
your 28 beliefs. She is the one you will
take a baptismal vow to according to the
church manual, current edition, page 45.
You must first uh affirm the fundamental
beliefs and then it's I think it's vow
number eight. You will affirm the spirit
of prophecy. That's it. This is her.
This is official. And she just said,
"Christ did not die on the cross for
anything." Now, what Adventists
sometimes do when I use this quote is
they stop reading about him out sins and
they I mean they stop reading uh the
second part which is where will the sin
stand? Because that quote is clear.
They're going to stand where? in this
physical
heavenly sanctuary that the Adventists
have cooked up since 1844. In other
words, Christ did, and this is an
argument that that I I can make and and
make clearly. The Christ of 7th Day
Adventism did not die for a single sin.
Period. He He couldn't. Um, matter of
fact, I I have something here I just
stumbled across when I was doing some
searches. I'll I'll get this up on my
screen here.
Yeah. So, in other words, this forgiving
of sin and and this quote here is by a
guy named William Branson, which I think
a lot of people probably have heard of.
While you're getting that set up, Jim, I
just want to quickly say here that I
have brought up on the screen, folks, as
well. Statement of confidence in the
writings of Ellen White. She corrects
inaccurate interpretations of scripture.
She was divinely inspired. The Adventist
Church has never repudiated this quote.
They've never said, "Nope, that quote is
is wrong." If that's somewhere
Adventist, and you want to show me that,
I'd be glad to see it. If it exists out
there, let me see it. But until then,
whatever the fundamental beliefs book
says, I don't care if it says we believe
that atonement was completed at the
cross. You know, some of their older
scholars are on record saying that we
believe in a completed incomplete
atonement. Oh, God. That there's a a a
completed incomplete atonement. Um but
nevertheless uh so what she says goes so
this quote stands no sins canceled at
Calvary. Unreal. Unreal. Right. So, look
at look at this quote here from Branson
in the Review and Herald and he's
talking about since the cross. Look what
I got yellow highlighted. Since the
cross. Why do we emphasize this point?
For the reason that this shows
conclusively that all the priestly work
of Christ in the heavenly sanctuary has
had to be performed since the cross.
None of it was done before he came to
the earth.
No one had a single sin forgiven
in this Adventist atonement as they put
in this magazine from looks like July
31st, 1934, right? Branson. And anybody
who reads Adventist literature is going
to know that that name.
Yeah. Yeah. And again, that's why it's
easy to say in Adventism, right along
with Ellen White, Christ didn't die for
a single sin. And Branson's right in
line with Ellen White and belief number
24 uh with a second phase of atonement.
Well, and other other pioneers as we're
going to see see here. So, yeah, let's
look at a couple pioneers. This is just
a a couple sampling here. We could look
at a number of these. Adventist pioneer
Uriah Smith, anti-trinitarian Aryan
heretic. Yep. What did he say regarding
this quote? The death of Christ and the
atonement are not the same thing.
Christian, I'm going to read this again.
The death of Christ and the atonement
are not the same thing. Jim, we talked
about propitiation, forgiveness,
reconciliation.
Y this is all tied to the atonement, the
death, burial, and resurrection of Jesus
Christ. This is a damnable statement
right here. Yep. And this relieves
matter of all difficulty. As if there is
difficulty. Christ did not make
atonement when he shed his blood upon
the cross. Let this fact be fixed
forever in the mind. Close quote. The
death that's an amazing quote by the
way. The death of Christ is not the
atonement. Folks, we have this hyperl on
the website. If you type in were sins
canceled at the cross,
you can get the hyperlink and go look at
the direct from the archive review and
herald. The date is down there. October
19, 1876. What a blasphemous demonic
statement. Only a person that fits the
bill of 1 Corinthians 18. Jim would say
such a statement. The cross is
foolishness to somebody who's perishing.
This fool was perishing.
Oh, absolutely. And I'm not using that
term fool in like a porative sense. I'm
using it in the biblical sense. Only a
fool would make such a statement. What a
statement.
What a statement. While Ellen White was
alive. Yep. And in conjunction with
Patriarchs and Prophets. Yep. And And
because I've I've I've used some Uriah
Smith quotes and people like to say,
"Well, she had problems with Uriah
Smith." Right. So, she should have
corrected him. That's exactly the point.
That's the one of the functions of the
spirit of prophecy. Read your book,
Seventh Day Adventist. I do. And chapter
18 says, "One of the functions of the
New Testament spirit of prophecy is to
protect the church from error." Yep. So,
if this was error, well, then we could
find the correction, but we don't. We We
find more of the same of this by other
authors, but you as we're going to see
momentarily. Excellent. Let them rip.
Jim, they shouldn't even call their
atonement two-faced when the first phase
wasn't even an atonement. No, it wasn't.
No, it wasn't. It wasn't even atonement.
They claimed there's a first phase and a
second phase. He just said no atonement
took place at the cross. I think they
like to say it because it sounds very
Christian. Yeah. This is what I mean.
Whenever I tell people that the SDA
church uses slippery language on the
topic, they'll say we believe the
atoning sacrifice took place at the
cross. And most Christians are not going
to pick up on the subtle nuance of
what's being said. They aren't saying
atonement took place there, just that
Christ sacrifice did. atonement would
take place later in heaven in a long
drawn out process that's still going on
today. This is because they've
wrongfully lumped underneath atonement
the second coming and the final judgment
on top of Jesus still dealing with sin
in a sanctuary building in heaven
wearing Levitical priesthood garments
when he's not even a Levitical priest is
unbelievable. Yeah. Now let's look at a
quote from WH Little John. Elder Little
John he's referred to in some of the the
writings influential pioneer. This is
what he said in the same paper in
response to the question. So you can
look at the quote. This is also in that
same article on the on answering
adventism.com folks. You can see the
same thing. It's hyperl. You can go to
the the from the archive the advent
review and sabbath herald to the
question. They're doing a mock
walkthrough in the paper and to the
question that's asked. Do you believe
sins were atoned for on the cross? This
is the answer that this influential SDA
pioneer says that the Adventist should
give. Quote, I believe that there is not
a, and he's talking about the Bible, a
Bible passage amongst those usually
employed to prove that the atonement
took place at the cross that will
justify such a conclusion. The doctrine
itself is contrary to reason.
When sin is once atoned for, it is fully
disposed of and can never be charged to
the account of the offender again. See,
he he recognizes that atonement is what
you mentioned earlier, correct? The
removal, experation.
To reason, therefore, that the sins of
those who are converted were atoned for
on the cross would be to argue that such
persons could not be lost. Close quote.
Again, Jim, only a person that fits the
first Corinthians 1:18 bill could say
say such a thing. The cross of Christ.
Go ahead. No, go ahead and finish. I
want to add something. Well, go ahead
and then I'll I'll have something else
to to piggyback on to that, but I want
to hear what you have to say because
because when you said that about him and
and I read these quotes by Adventist, I
think of first John 2:22
and it says, "Who is the liar but he who
denies that Jesus is the Christ?"
And that's what that Jesus is the
Christ. That means that Jesus is the
Messiah. That means that which Jesus was
prophesied to come to do. As we read in
Isaiah 53, who is the liar? But who
denies the messiahship of Jesus is
another way to say it. And then what
does John say? This is Antichrist.
He who denies the father and the son.
What you have on screen right here is
antirist.
It is a denial of the messiahship of
Christ. And John tells us that's
Antichrist and that's what the spirit of
Adventism is. Here it is. As far as I'm
concerned, this is a demonic statement.
Oh yeah. This is this is I mean it just
I've I've read these I don't know how
many times and every time I read them I
just think to myself,
wow. Wow. Um but furthermore on this a
question for you, Jim.
How does this fare? Again, like we said
with Uriah Smith, with the Ellen White
quote, how does this fair with the 28
fundamental beliefs book, what we just
read earlier about what they were
saying, oh, atonement was completed at
the cross, etc. These pioneers,
including Ellen White, couldn't even
sign off on what's the book today. No,
no, no, no. This is something that I see
in all the non-Christian groups that I
study, and that is when you look at
their early writings,
uh, I guess pun intended, right? When
you look at their early writings and
then you look at their their later
writings, you know, 2020, whatever it
is, one, two, three, 2018, compared to
what they did in the 1830s, 40s or 50s.
Oh, they're sophisticated now because
they they're much more careful today.
And and and it's hard for me to put my
to draw a line, but I'm going to say
probably about the 1950s,
1960s.
non-Christian groups like the Adventists
became a little more careful and a
little more measured because in the
beginning when we see quotes here by
Uriah Smith, Ellen White, Elder Little
John, hey um the gloves are off. It's
unvarnished. We're I'm really going to
tell you what I think. And they do and
they did. But today they try to dress it
up. They put lipstick on that pig, cover
it up. And that's what they did in the
28 Beliefs book. I think it's them being
a more sophisticated, more trying to be
in tune with what's happening where back
in the day here, the quote you have on
screen, oh no, no, they didn't care.
They let you know who they really were.
This is not just an alternate atonement
theory, folks. No, I know there's people
out there thinking, well, no, this isn't
like, you know, Christ Victor or ransom
theory or penal substitutionary. No, no.
Th this is anti-Christian heresy.
Atonement didn't take place at the
cross. Utterly shameful. But with
regards to the Ellen White quote, the
claim is that the door of the most holy
place was opened in 1844. No, it wasn't.
It wasn't. I It was opened at his
ascension upon his entrance into the
true most holy place, which is heaven
itself, bringing access to all of those
who are in him. You can't be like Paul
says in Ephesians 4:7. And I talked
about this in uh my video earlier this
week. So if you haven't seen that,
folks, go and check it out. Um it's
titled No, Seventh Day Adventism is not
Christian. Here's why. You can't
understand Paul's words in Ephesians 4
where he says he has raised us up with
him and then seated us in heaven with
him. Talking about being in Christ, it's
as if we lived the life he lived, died
the death he died, was buried the way he
was buried, and raised the way he was
raised. This is what's typified to us in
our baptism.
It it signs the promises of God to us in
the person and work of Christ. Well,
then we're also seated with him in the
heavenlies. You can't have that in this
investigative judgment. Your sin's still
on record, but you're seated presently
in Christ in the heavenlies. It does not
work. No, it doesn't. So, no, this is
again why understanding union with
Christ is so vital. But I want to look
at the scriptures here again because
this is vitally important as well. And
that's Hebrews 10:19-22.
And what does it say? I've quoted this I
don't even know how many times on the
channel. We're going to keep quoting
this. I mean, there is just power in
this
quote. Therefore, brothers, since we
have confidence to enter the holy
places, plural by the blood of Jesus. So
Jim, how did and who could enter the
holy places before?
Only the high priest with the blood of
an animal, right? But only one once a
year, right?
So after telling us back in 98 that
while the Levitical priesthood work was
going on, the way was closed off to the
believer. It was only open to the high
priest once a year.
But after telling us that and now
telling us the contrast which is what
the whole book of Hebrews is about how
Jesus is better.
He says therefore brothers since we the
believer have confidence to enter the
holy places by the blood of Jesus not
the blood of an animal the blood of
Jesus by the new and living way that he
opened for us through the curtain.
That's that second veil behind the veil
that is through his flesh.
All the temple imagery, including the
building itself, pointed to Jesus. He's
the bread of life, the light of the
world. The curtain is his flesh,
his temple. And since we have a great
high priest over the house of God, let
us draw near with a true heart in full
assurance of faith, with our hearts
sprinkled clean from an evil conscience.
The blood of animals couldn't do that,
and our bodies washed with pure water.
The true curtain that we enter, the most
holy place is Jesus Christ's own flesh,
the incarnation, the person and work of
Jesus. By faith, a person enters into
him and by virtue of such, they have
access into the presence of God with
boldness. This did not happen in 1844.
This is why in my video this past week
regarding the atonement, like I
mentioned, I mentioned not I said uh
erroneously earlier Ephesians 4, it's
Ephesians 2:7.
that by being in Christ, a person is
presently seated with Christ in the
heavenlies. There is now there's a now
and a not yet component. I'm not
physically there yet, but by virtue of
being in Christ who is and is seated
again, showing the work deal of dealing
with sin is finished. I am there. The
spirit's given to me as a down payment
from God guaranteeing that inheritance.
Ephesians 4, Ephesians 1, 2 Corinthians
1, 2 Corinthians 5. None of this is
possible in this investigative judgment
paradigm. Your sin is still standing
against you, which means the barrier is
still there as Christ is tearing it down
still. Yet, you're seated with Christ in
the heavenlies. You're reconciled to
God, but your sin still stands against
you. Not possible. And like you
mentioned earlier, where in the Bible
does it talk about a final atonement?
Adventists will say, "No, no, no, no,
no. We're not saying it's a different
atonement, just a second phase." No. I I
know that. Where's that in the Bible?
Not there. Atone Atonement involved
blood. Hebrews 9:22,
atonement involves blood. Without the
shedding of blood, key word, shedding,
there's no forgiveness of sins. So, if
Jesus is dealing with sin in heaven, he
has to be shedding blood because it's
part of the atonement. Yet, he shed his
blood one time at Calvary. The author
told us in Hebrews, he's not shedding
blood again up in heaven. But even so,
Jim, let's hypothetically roll with this
theory. I like to do this a lot with
them. I'll say, 'Well, let's
hypothetically roll with this because
there's tons of problems down the road.
You're just kicking the can further. You
know, Jesus is in heaven using blood to
deal with sins. How did the blood get
there? Is it external to himself? Is it
the blood that's flowing through his
physical body
because I've reached out to their own
scholars and I was talking to you about
this yesterday. I they won't give me a
straight answer. I can't find a straight
because none of them want to go there
and you had a theory that well they
didn't think that far down the road and
that's true because here's the problem
folks as you're going to see here
momentarily. Well, let me get to the the
slides before I uh spoil it and we'll
just we'll look because this is what
Ellen White says about sin transference
into heaven. Okay.
Quote, this is great controversy. Page
421. Remember folks, he said these words
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord.
As anciently the sins of the people were
placed by faith upon the sin offering
and through its blood transferred in
figure to the earthly sanctuary, so in
the new covenant, the sins of the
repentant are by faith placed upon
Christ and transferred in fact to the
heavenly sanctuary. So they teach that
the first phase of atonement gets one's
sins transferred by means of Jesus's
blood into heaven where they defile the
heavenly sanctuary which then needs
cleansed. The second phase of the
atonement occurs at the end of Jesus's
investigative judgment when he finally
transfers those sins from the sanctuary
onto Satan who carries them into the
lake of fire. Thus, heaven will finally
be cleansed and believers are finally
fully forgiven. Now, like I said, I've
been trying to get answers from their
scholars on how exactly this works. And
I don't think the SDA pioneers actually
thought this mess through well enough
because is Jesus there with literal
blood in heaven? Ellen claims that sins
in fact, not just in type on this, she
says in fact are transferred to heaven.
It's there that sins that it's it's
these sins that then defile heaven. the
sins that are transferred when you
confess and that means through it uh
Christ's blood is a vehicle. So does
this mean he's using literal blood in
heaven? If so, how is that blood taken
there? One could only assume in his
body, which would mean that Jesus has
sin laden blood coursing through his
body. That's right. Because it's the
blood of Christ that transfers them
there in fact to heaven. And if any
Adventist doesn't like what you said, I
would love for them to then tell us how
the how the uh sins uh got to heaven.
Folks, I've reached out to Jed Lake.
I've reached out to scholars. I I and
they've sent me their seminary
textbooks. That's all good and dandy. I
I'm still not seeing it. It's not
answering the question because I don't
think this has been thought through
enough because this is a serious
problem. To deal with sins and to do
atonement, there has to be blood
involved. So, how is Jesus working with
blood in heaven? How did he take it
there? Is it external to himself in a
jar? Like, I'm not trying to be, you
know, I'm not trying to mock. I'm asking
seriously, how did it get there? Because
if it's transferred there by his blood
and it's in his body, you have sin laden
blood coursing through the body of Jesus
Christ. Furthermore, the Bible never
describes the blood of Christ ever
defiling anything ever. the exact
opposite. It cleanses. Ephesians 1:7, 1
John 1:7, Colossians 1:7. Get that, Jim.
What are the chances? 17 in all three
places. John 6:53, Jesus says his blood
is lifegiving. Hebrews 9, Jesus' blood
purifies the conscience, showing the
Levitical priest couldn't do which what
Christ's blood does because it was
recurring. It was a constant reminder of
one's sins. Yet Jesus's single sacrifice
purifies and cleanses the conscience.
Nowhere does scripture ever describe co
Christ's blood being a transference
vehicle for sin. It's the cleansing
mechanism, not a conduit or transfer
device. This is a perfect example, Jim,
of how they don't properly understand
the difference between Christ's
sacrifice and the sacrifice of animals
because his blood actually dealt with
sin in finality. It didn't transport it.
Oh, I I know that's that's so heretical
because you're you're right. putting sin
in and on Christ and you're putting sin
in what is supposed to be the holy place
of God. Yeah. Well, and what like like
we mentioned earlier, Peter tells us,
think about this verse alone, Jim, in
contrast to those quotes from Little
John and Uriah Smith,
Christ bore our sins in his body on the
cross. Period.
Period.
No. No sins were canceled at the cross.
Oh, so he was bearing the sins, but what
it means by bearing the sins was he was
just paying the penalty, right? No. What
did Isaiah say? I That's why I was going
over that and ad nauseium like it's
mentioned four times in those 12 verses.
He bore our iniquities at the cross and
made peace by the blood of his cross,
reconciling to himself all that's on
heaven and on earth, which is why he has
all authority to rule and reign as a
king from heaven right now. That flies
in the face of what they were saying.
But again, sins are not transferred to
heaven to be remembered and
investigated. No, she said that the sins
are then transferred to then rest there
to then be investigated to see which
ones are going to be expuned
essentially. Except no, Jeremiah and
Hebrews like we looked at earlier, we
read Jeremiah 31:31-34.
One of the promises of the new covenant
is that God remembers a person's sins no
more. What does she say here? In the new
covenant, the sins of the repentant are
by faith placed upon Christ and
transferred. No, they are not. No, they
are not. Jeremiah 31, the new covenant,
a promise of the new covenant. God
remembers the sins no more. It's right
there, folks. If you're an Adventist and
you're uncomfortable, that's good.
You got to wrestle with this. Are you
willing to go wherever the truth leads
at all costs?
It this is so plain. This is so This is
spiritual milk, Jim.
A promise of the new covenant. God
remembers our sins no more. This is
completely contradictory to this entire
doctrine. They're not transferred.
Any thoughts before moving to the next
quote? Uh, no. I know. I think we can go
on to the next one. Okay. So, in Christ
in his sanctuary, which is a compilation
book of all her statements regarding
this specific topic, here's what she
says.
quote, "The work of the investigative
judgment and the blotting out of sins is
to be accomplished before the second
advent of the Lord. Since the dead are
to be judged out of the things written
in the books, it's impossible that the
sins of men should be blotted out until
after the judgment at which their cases
are to be investigated." But the Apostle
Peter distinctly states that the sins of
believers will be blotted out when the
times of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord and he shall send
Jesus Christ. Acts 3:19-20.
when the investigative judgment closes,
Christ will come and his reward will be
with him to give to every man as his
work shall be. Close quote. So, she
butchers Acts 3:19 here, which is common
for SDAs who claim Peter here is
referring to some time long off into the
future. He's quoting Joel 2. Apparently,
Peter quoting Joel was referring to
1844, Jim. I don't know if you knew
that. Um, but apparently he had 1844 on
the mind when he told the hearers to
turn to Christ such that they will be
forgiven of their sins and they'll be
remembered no more.
That that's apparently what he's
referring to because then two pages
later, she says this.
At the time appointed for the judgment,
the close of the 2300 days, Daniel 8:14
in 1844, began the work of investigation
and blotting out of sins. All who have
ever taken upon themselves the name of
Christ must pass its searching scrutiny.
Both the living and the dead are to be
judged out of those things which were
written in the books according to their
works. Close quote. Again, no sins
canceled at Calvary. Right? Because when
were sins blotted out? You have an
underlined in red. They were blotted out
1844. Starting in 1844, not completely
starting. And it's still going now. It's
still going present. did not die on the
cross for a single sin. Why? Because
they were blotted out
after 1844.
This is in complete contradiction,
folks, to the book of Hebrews saying
Jesus is seated again as a priest, high
priest, king after the order of
MelkiseDC, who's both a king and a
priest. She has Jesus still working on
sins. If sin started getting blotted out
in 1844, that means all of what
scripture says regarding union with
Christ would not be applicable to anyone
from the cross to 1844 and really not
anyone now because they don't know if
their sins have actually been blotted
out yet. Right? No sins were blotted
out. She says Isaiah says it's sin to
that that separates a person from God.
No one was reconciled between 1844 or
1811 to or uh 33 to 18 1844 1811 years
and even after like I said you can't
know if your name's come up yet but I
want to look at Colossians 2 because
this is a big one 13-15 people often
wrongly assert I'm going to argue that
Colossians 2 is talking about either all
of the law or the in the SDA church's
case the ceremonial law being nailed to
the cross. I will contend this is not
what the text is saying for a big
reason. I have an article on this for
those that are curious on the site. You
can type in was the law nailed to the
cross. It will pop up. But I want to
look at just a second here.
Colossians 2:13-15. What does it say?
And you who were dead in your trespasses
and the uncircumcision of your flesh,
God made alive together with him. Again,
this is language of union with Christ.
Having forgiven us all our trespasses.
Jim, you talked about forgiveness
earlier. There it is. We looked at the
Greek word around forgiveness. It's not
put on parole to then be investigated
while on probation.
That's not what's going on. He's
forgiven us all our sins by cancelling
the record of debt that stood against us
with its legal demands. This he set
aside, nailing it to the cross, he
disarmed the rulers and authorities and
put them to open shame by triumphing
over them in him. So Adventists rely on
the King James rendering of this because
instead of the record of death that
stood against us, it says the
handwriting of ordinances. They try and
then import into that phrase the
ceremonial law which Moses wrote on
parchment. And they'll say that's the
exact word that's used in in
Deuteronomy. That's what was nailed to
the cross. But no, that isn't what the
text says. So, from an article on our
site titled, "Was the law nailed to the
cross?" Like I just mentioned,
let's look at this here. Bring this
over.
So, I'm going to bring this full screen.
Let's see what it says here regarding
what was nailed. Starting here, says
Paul gives a synopsis of Christ's nature
in Colossians 2 9-12.
and that by being in him, the believer,
union with Christ, they are inwardly
circumcised through baptism, buried with
Christ and raised. Then he states, which
we just read, that while we were dead in
our sins, God made us alive with Christ.
And you who were dead in your trespasses
and the uncircumcision of your flesh,
God made alive together with him, having
forgiven us all our trespasses. All this
is key. Prior to transitioning to
discussion about any sort of cancelling,
Paul starts by explaining that we were
dead in our sins, but by being in
Christ, we were raised to spiritual
newness of life and he forgave us all
our sins. The focus is on sin and sin
being done away with. So then in verse
14, he says, "The sin debt that stood
against us, a debt that we could not
pay, was done away with by being nailed
to the cross." The Greek word, Jimmy,
you were talking about the Greek
earlier. You don't have to be a Greek
grimarian for this either. You can look
this up, folks. It's hyperlink for you
right there. Click it and it'll take you
right to the the lexicon. The Greek word
for record of debt or handwriting of
ordinances is kerograph. That's the
transliteration of it. And it means a
handwritten IOU or a certificate of
legal indebtedness. It's a legal term in
Greek. And this is the only place it's
used in scripture which is called a
hoxama.
Jesus equated sin with debt in the
Lord's prayer. So if you look at Matthew
6:12, "And forgive us our debts as we
have also forgiven our debtors." And
then compare it with Luke 11:4.
and forgive us our sins, for we
ourselves forgive everyone who has
indebted to us, and lead us not into
temptation. You'll see that Matthew
documents it as debts, and Luke
documents it as sins and indebtedness.
Sin is a legal debt. It's earned a wage
of death. We cannot pay this debt, but
Jesus could. And legal debts can
lawfully be transferred. So, what was
nailed to the cross was our sin debt
that we've incurred for sinning against
God. Jesus Christ bore our sins in his
body on the cross
and then he was nailed to the cross.
That's how the record of debt was nailed
to the cross and done away with. It was
paid in full by Jesus himself by paying
the debt of death. This passage destroys
the SDA teaching of the investigative
judgment which claims that Christ is
still dealing with sin contrary to
Hebrews 9:26
in a sanctuary in heaven where he's
still blotting out sins. The SDA church
rejects the legal or penal aspect of
sin. But that is what is in focus in
Colossians 2:14. Sin not ceremonial
laws. So Jim, I know that was a lot
there, but any thoughts that you'd like
to add with that before moving to our
final sections here? I was just thinking
as you were finishing that up that so
far this whole video has shown so many
scripture verses that absolutely refute
the Adventist concept of a two-faced
atonement in a physical heavenly
sanctuary. It's astounding. If an
Adventist is serious and and willing to
search for biblical truth,
re-watch this. Pull every scripture
verse that's been cited. Look it up and
you're going to find it will not
reconcile to Adventism, but you'll find
its true meaning in the scriptures. And
that's this is just another one in a
string of text that cited this whole
video. I mean, Jim, we're trying to
cover like I mean, we're going to
prophecy about the atonement. We're
going to what the scriptures that the
Greek says about uh forgiveness,
purification, reconciliation. Um, you
know, I mean, like you said, the
the transference of sin, not the blood
never being a transference device. It
wasn't taken daily in in the daily work
for the people and sprinkled be behind
the veil. That never that that's not
what happened. That only happened on two
occasions. The part of the promise of
the new covenant is that God remembers
our sins no more. We're forgiven all our
sins. Colossians 1:20. It was at the
cross that he reconciled all things to
himself. So yeah, um I mean hopefully
God will use it. Adventists, I hope that
you will you will look into these things
for yourself. Now, regarding the
regarding the patriarchs and prophets
quote, "No sins canceled at the cross."
I want to look at a few statements from
an Adventist scholar Dennis 410 or some
people say 14. Um this is from a paper
titled Ellen G. White's conceptual
understanding of the sanctuary and
hermeneutics. And then under the heading
that's titled the record and
cancellation of sin, let me get this
right up here.
This is Oh, I got to bring that up
first. There we go.
Me try this one more time.
Okay.
So, under the heading of the record and
cancellation of sin, this is what he
says. He's commenting on that quote that
we just read from patriarchs and
prophets. He says, quote, "This brings
us to the third parallel which deals
with the record of sin after confession
and repentance." So folks, we just
talked about the record of sin. Where
was that canceled, Jim?
That was canled on the cross where Jesus
bore the sins, right? The blood of
Christ, while it was to release, so now
he's going to quote the Ellen White
quote here. The blood of Christ while it
was to release the repentant sinner from
the condemnation of the law was not to
cancel the sin. It would stand on record
in the sanctuary until the final
atonement. So in the type the blood of
the sin offering removed the sin from
the penitent but it rested in the
sanctuary until the day of atonement. So
then he says, ' Ellen White's thoughts
here differentiate between the repentant
sinner who's released from the guilt of
sins and the record of sins transferred
to the sanctuary. Based on her reading
of the Levitical daily and yearly
services, she concluded or she concludes
that while the sinner is released from
the guilt of sin, because the innocent
sacrifice has paid the price through
death, the sin has been transferred to
the sanctuary and abides there in the
presence of God until the day of
atonement services. Again, her
comparison is from the superior reality
in heaven to the shadow on earth. The
day of atonement ceremonies in the
earthly sanctuary were patterned after
the divine way of dealing with sin.
Close quote. So people's sins are
transferred to heaven by the blood of
Christ to rest in the sanctuary in the
presence of God. Sin is in the presence
of God. Jim, you know, there's a a
reason why first of all, Leviticus 16
and the day of atonement.
I an Adventist ought to read this and
think about it now because I like to you
know Adventists will just
off the cuff and say well our atonements
like the atonement and the day of
atonement in Leviticus 16 first of all
do you know there's five atonements in
Leviticus 16.
So which one are you talking about?
Five.
um
that
when he says okay the so the day of
atonement was actually to cleanse the
sanctuary because it was polluted by the
sins of the people worshiping there it
was not to collect sins yeah the people
it's because the and the people were
sinners yes and that's why the the mercy
seat was sprinkled with the blood the
sanctuary itself and the altar were
cleansed and then one of the last acts
and we're going to get to that I think
probably here in a minute was you We had
we had one goat that was killed and the
blood was to to cleanse the altar to
cleanse the place where God met with his
people. That's why the sanctuary was
cleansed. God doesn't reside in sin.
That's why the sanctuary was cleansed in
Leviticus
to clean it. And what you just read was
the exact opposite.
We're storing sins in the sanctuary
where in Leviticus it says get them out
and do this yearly, but now we're
storing them. That's that's crazy. Well,
then he continues
in saying the fourth comparison. Now,
this is under a heading titled end time
judgment and yearly judgment. So, again,
in their system, folks, for those that
do not know, they have lumped under
atonement, the second coming. There
there's a whole bunch of other things
they've lumped in there. It's not it's
not the cross of Christ. That's just the
atoning sacrifice. That's phase one.
That was basically to make the conduit
vehicle of transference possible to then
move them to heaven. They have this
whole theory of transference through the
blood. They're transferred from the
person to Christ and then Christ's blood
to the sanctuary, then from the
sanctuary to Satan to then the lake of
fire. It's this long chain of things. So
he says under the heading end time
judgment, yearly judgment. In this
fourth comparison, we see that Ellen
White believes in the double efficiency
or efficacy of the blood of Christ to be
at the same time the means of
transferring to heaven the sins of the
repentant sinners according to Leviticus
4 and to be the atoning sacrifice to
cleanse the heavenly sanctuary from the
record of sins according to Leviticus
16:15-17
which is what you just mentioned. Many
theologians have wondered how the blood
of Christ could at the same time be used
to transfer our guilt to heaven in the
antitypical daily service and also have
the cleansing power to accomplish the
yearly ritual of the day of atonement.
This provides no difficulty for Ellen
White. Christ's blood accomplishes both
the daily and yearly blood rituals. Jim,
what are your thoughts on that?
What a mess. What a just a theological
mess.
Not only like I like I just said a
minute ago, do they confuse what
actually happens and why the day of
atonement service, but they confused
that with the sin offerings of
individuals and I think because he
mentioned um Leviticus 4. Now, Ellen
White mentioned that earlier, by the
way, and I didn't comment on that when
she said it was the repentant sinner,
and she cited Leviticus 4, who would
come and put his hand. She said he would
come, the repentant sinner would come
and put their hand on the offering. And
you know what? I read Leviticus 4. The
sinner doesn't do that. The priest does
that. I mean, she can't even get her
scripture right uh in in in that regard
for the the sin offering. They're mixing
up two different
sin purposes here. One is for the
personal reconciliation of the Jewish
sinner in Leviticus 4. In Leviticus 16,
the day of atonement, again, it's not
about the individual. Nobody repented in
the day of atonement. By the way, I'm
I'm I'm waiting for an Adventist to tell
me nobody repented of their sins in the
day of atonement. Yes, they had their
sins forgiven corporately by the
priests, but that was to cleanse the
sanctuary where they were all going to
show up, but nobody repented in
Leviticus 16. So, yeah, they're just
completely mixing up. They do not
understand actually the day of
atonement, which is to cleanse a
sanctuary where people would go and make
the sacrifices that they did in
Leviticus 4.
Well, and not just that, Jim, but it's
the day of atonement, not the hund and
some odd years of atonement. Um, it's
funny that they they like to take things
hyperliterally when it's convenient, but
then when it comes, well, the day of
atonement, eh, that's the day is
typological of a hund and some odd years
and it'll keep being racked up until,
well, it's finished.
But where we were previously in the
great controversy on pageuh 420, I
quoted this earlier. Um, Ellen White
falsely claims this.
Important truths concerning the
atonement are taught by the typical
service. So that's what we're talking
about here is the typical service. A
substitute was accepted in the sinner's
steed. Great. Okay. Like we're tracking
along wonderfully. But the sin was not
canceled by the blood of the victim. Oh,
there we go. It's just I mean
[Music]
a means was thus provided by which it
was transferred to the sanctuary. Again
folks, this is not true. When the
sacrificed animal died as a sin offering
at the entrance of the sanctuary, the
payment for the confessed sins was
complete.
The priest would then collect its blood
which had become what scripture calls
most holy. It says this over and over
and over after that's happened. It
becomes most holy. Leviticus 456
25 26 27. It's over and over. Numbers
18:9. You were quoting Numbers 18:7
earlier. Two verses later it says when
this happens that becomes most holy. The
fat of the animal was then placed on the
altar of burnt offering which again
confirmed its holiness because Exodus
29:37 states that whatever touches that
altar will be holy.
So depending on the circumstances either
the blood or portions of its flesh which
was eaten by the priest those were also
brought into the sanctuary again making
them most holy. Numbers 18:9.
The blood being brought into the
sanctuary is not what defiled it. It was
evidence that the payment was made in
full. The priest would then announce to
the Israelite that an atonement for him
before the Lord had been made and that
he was forgiven of his trespasses.
Again, Leviticus 456.
The blood was not brought into the
sanctuary to transfer sins. The
atonement had already been made and
announced when the sacrificials when the
sacrificial animals blood was shed,
which is precisely what happened at
Calvary when Jesus shed his blood
announcing forgiveness. And as the high
priest declared, "It is finished to
Telsty."
As soon as the Levitical priest Jim
received the sin offering, that sin
offering became most holy. And we're
told in Leviticus 6, uh, Leviticus 6:27,
that after that, merely touching the
dead flesh of the sin offering also
transferred more holiness to the priest,
not defilement.
Which means instead of sin transferring
the sacrifice which has become most holy
actually transferred more holiness to
the priests and into the sanctuary. The
holy priest was only allowed to touch
handle and work with the holy and most
holy things. That's Exodus 28 30 28 38.
It says that the priest's ministry bore
away the sin from the offering making
that sacrifice most holy. The sin was
removed from it not transferred and
moved into the sanctuary. So all that to
say, no, there's no transference of sin
going on which is necessary for this
whole theory to work.
It's not there. Are you seeing anywhere,
Jim, where it's talking about sins being
transferred here and then transferred?
No. No. Just the idea of transferring
sins to a sanctuary is is just
heretical. They're getting all this
because they don't understand what the
cleansing in view is. They think, well,
it transferred because it defiled it.
No, the the sinner defiled it by by the
person doing the work being a fallen
human and they had to clean and cleanse
because the people doing the work were
sinners. Jesus isn't a sinner.
This again was all simply typological of
a great truth that pointed to the person
and work of Jesus. Not well it pictured
sins being transferred into the
sanctuary for then when Jesus came he'll
transfer sins into the sanctuary. No,
you're you're missing you're completely
missing what's going on. Well, he
continues in this Jim in this next
paragraph here to say Ellen White's
identification of this scapegoat as
Satan. So now we're going to transition
into our final part here. So they have
this idea of when you the first phase of
atonement made the ability of
transference possible. They were then
transferred to heaven, which is what's
going on now. Every time you confess, it
transfers to heaven by means of Jesus's
blood. And it all blotted out from the
book. And you mentioned earlier that
there's an angel assigned over each
person to document down their sins to
transfer. They have this whole chain of
command where God uses these angels to
copy down and then it's transferred to
your book which is transferred to heaven
and then Jesus will go down the book in
the investigative judgment when your
name comes up to then eventually if
you've confessed it blot that sin out
but if you haven't it's going to stand
on record yada yada. Then we move to how
the people who make it through the
investigative judgment, how their sin is
then finally transferred and expedated.
We've mentioned this a number of times
tonight. Removed. The Bible says they
were removed at Calvary by the lamb of
God who takes away the sins of the
world, who bore them in his body on the
cross. So he says here though, Ellen
White Ellen White's identification of
the scapegoat as Satan is closely
integrated with her understanding of the
origins of the cosmic great controversy.
Ah.
Ah. The great controversy theme. That's
what this is being filtered through
because that's the paradigm. That's how
we read the Bible through the great
controversy lens. She understood Satan
to be a real evil angelic being and the
originator of the concept of sin
and the instigator of all sins that
caused the death of Christ. Therefore,
as a matter of universal justice, she
believes Satan is ultimately responsible
for the death of the son of God. This,
she also believes was the intent of the
scapegoat ritual on the day of
atonement, which foreshadowed Satan's
destruction as the author of sin. Thus,
will Satan be forever banished from the
presence of God and his people, and he
will be blotted from existence in the
final destruction of sin and sinners.
That's great controversy. 422, paragraph
5. So of course he is essentially
quoting the desire of ages here where
Ellen White said this
quote could one sin have been found in
Christ had he in one particular yielded
to Satan to escape the terrible torture
the enemy of God and man would have
triumphed. Christ bowed his head and
died but he held fast his faith and his
submission to God. And she's going to
quote Revelation 12:10. And I heard a
loud voice saying in heaven, "Now is
come salvation and strength in the
kingdom of our God and the power of his
Christ. For the accuser of our brethren
is cast down, which accused them before
our God day and night." Satan saw that
his disguise was torn away. His
administration was laid open before the
unfallen angels and before the heavenly
universe. He had revealed himself as a
murderer.
By shedding the blood of the son of God,
he had uprooted himself from the
sympathies of the heavenly beings. Close
quote. Jim,
we read earlier Isaiah,
Abraham with Isaac. Yeah. Satan shed the
blood of Jesus. Right. Right. All I got
to All I was thinking of as you're
reading that is she obviously did not
read her Bible. She did not read Isaiah
53:10
where it says it was God's will to crush
him.
Satan's will. Yeah. God used the means
of of wicked Roman soldiers. Yes. To
bring about his will. Acts chapter 4.
That's it. Abraham and Isaac is a
depiction of the sacrifice of Christ.
It's the father sacrificing the son, not
an adversary swooping in to kill the
son. Yeah. It was because of
Okay, go ahead. And you know, in this
this whole paragraph here, I'm thinking,
you know, you see all these biblical
sounding words and phrases.
And um I'm I'm looking at it here. You
only got what? One Bible citation in it.
Just one. But all these biblical
sounding words and phrases, I Where does
the Bible say Satan killed Jesus? Give
me the Bible verse. you know, u and I
could do that with where does the Bible
say Satan had an administration that was
laid open before unfallen angels on and
on and on. This just this is a work of
um science fiction
and and again it's Antichrist. I always
I always say it's a a nightmare
fanfiction. Oh yeah. Yeah. It's just a
bunch of excess and they think that well
she never adds to the Bible. She just
comments on what's there. She gives us
further insight into what's present.
Yeah. Okay. Well, then she talks about
Satan repenting and he he saw an angel
that was there outside the gates of
heaven to seek an inquiry and and have a
meeting with Jesus. Oh, she never adds
to the Bible though, right? Right. You
just have this whole dialogue between
her and Satan in the Garden of Eden in
Patriarchs and Prophets pages 53 through
55. Um, all that's in the Bible, right?
This whole dialogue where Satan was was
apparently not actually the serpent. He
was actually hiding somewhere and he was
manipulating the serpent doing a uh
deadly camouflage miracle as Steven
Boore says. But nevertheless, Jim, in
relation to what he said previously,
Dennis 14 and Ellen White's quote.
Uh Jim, did Jesus suffer for Satan's
sins? No. Who whose sins were were whose
iniquity was placed? That was why I was
emphasizing that. so hard earlier when
we were talking about Isaiah 53.
It was because of my sin, Jim, and your
sin that Christ was killed, not Satan.
Right? Jesus did not die for Satan.
Think of John 1:29. John the Baptist
said, "What?
Behold, behold the lamb of God who takes
away the sins of the world of the
world." Oh, no. I thought maybe I You
know what? Actually, I got my good old
clear word Bible in front of me. Yeah, I
I had to open it up because it probably
says, "Behold Satan who takes away the
sins of the world." Yeah. Or you'll have
That's what it says. Yeah. Five
paragraphs of Jack of Jack Blanco's
commentary just straight up written into
the text. But it doesn't say that,
right? Jesus died for those who put him
there. Human sinners, humans.
That's the sin that that Jesus died for.
Satan didn't kill Jesus. That's not the
propitiation that took place was not
because Jesus was killing. And I I know
their response to this, Jim. I don't
know if you've heard it before. It's
just it's like, oh my goodness, the
grasping at straws. She's not saying
that Satan literally is the one that
killed him. She's saying that because
Satan's actions, he's the reason that
Jesus was then had to be put on the
cross. No, folks. This was a plan before
the foundation of the world. before
Satan was created. This whole this whole
thing assumes when they have this
excuse, you're just assuming the great
controversy paradigm. You're just
assuming the plan B that Jesus proposed
this plan of salvation prior to or right
after the fall of man, which I talk
about in the video I did on Monday.
Satan did not shed the blood of Christ.
The father did. I know Adventists do not
like that because the Adventist God
would never do such a thing. But that's
the facts. So deal with it. Yeah. Read
it 53. You also mentioned Now Yes. Now,
you also mentioned Leviticus 16. Yeah.
But Leviticus 16 says nothing about the
scapegoat representing responsibility.
That is key to this whole thing. They
just assume this. I've talked with I
don't know how many SDAs about the
scapegoat. Hundreds at this point. Every
single time. The lynch or the the the
hinge upon which this whole thing swings
is the claim that well it's whole cloth
Ellen White read into the text. She's
the one that says the scapegoat
represented responsibility. And I've
been waiting for years for an SDA to be
able to show us that the scapegoat
represented a party responsible for sin.
That's the crux of their whole view of
the scapegoat. But as we will see, Ellen
White says exactly that, but it's not
there. But as he stated, they teach that
the first phase of the atonement only
dealt with sin transference. Christ paid
the penalty for sin. Calvary was only
where the sacrifice of Christ took
place. Sins are then transferred to
heaven by Christ's blood to sit in the
presence of God. And Jesus began
blotting the mount in 1844. That's what
he that's all what he said there. Now my
question to you Jim before looking at
our final set of quotes here and then
wrapping things up. What was the
function of the scapegoat?
First of all, let me say that there are
several theological thoughts on on on
what this is. And I'm going to say
nobody can say they have the one right
true answer which explains the
scapegoat. So, let me say this about the
scapegoat and what is known. First of
all, the scapegoat was not a sacrifice.
It didn't die a sacrificial death
in look at Leviticus 16:21. And here's a
really key point about the scapegoat. It
describes it as having two hands laid on
the scapegoat. You look at every other
sacrifice in the Old Testament, there's
only one hand laid on the sacrifice.
This one had two. Now the thought is
that they had two hands because it's a
transference of the sins of the nation
that they were using to cleanse the
sanctuary that they had traveling with
them and and transfer the sin to the but
it's not a sacrifice. It had two hands,
not one. Um just another thought,
two-handed transference rights. You'll
see this in the scriptures. one example.
There's several others. Deuteronomy
34:9, that's Moses and Joshua. When
Moses transfers his authority to Joshua,
so it's a transference.
Now, the live scapegoat in in 1621, it
transferred the sins away from the
nation of Israel into the wilderness. It
wasn't sacrificed.
So, there were two goats sacrificed. One
was sacrificed and the blood was put on
the altar to cleanse the sanctuary. This
is to transfer the sins of the nation
away from the nation. Now, here's here's
scholarly thought on what the scapegoat
is. The scapegoat is thought in in in uh
at the time in Israel, the wilderness
represented u a place of where demons
reside, where evil reside. So, the
scapegoat was sent to the wilderness in
a place where it would be, as Leviticus
16:22 says, cut off. It doesn't say
sacrifice. It just says cut off. Now the
name Ael, right, for the scapegoat. It's
thought to be a demon that lived in the
wilderness.
Jewish literature later in Book of
Enoch, they called Ael the name of a
demon. Remember I said demon twice. I
didn't say Satan once yet. Nobody thinks
that. Others, some other scholars, and I
want to say this probably a minority
believe Aziel. It's a rare Hebrew noun
meaning complete destruction.
In any case, no one, no scholar source
and nor is there any other extra
biblical source to say Ael is Satan
who's going to bear the sins of everyone
at the end of time. Now in in the
ancient neareastern world and we can
talk about Hittites too in particular
who were next door neighbors to the to
the Israelites
all believe that the domain of the
wilderness housed that was the domain of
demons and to send the sin away was to
send the sin to the wilderness to the
domain of the demons and to do then to
send it away.
What's clear Azel is not Satan himself.
AL never accused in the scripture as
being the source of sin. This was a
transference. Two hands transferred it
away and it's the day of atonement which
is an annual event and they did this
year after year after year.
Yeah. So you well you mentioned a number
of things there. So to piggyback off
that this is one of the few areas where
transference is actually happening.
And the thing that's interesting, man,
it is when you come out of Adventism, I
understand that when you think about it
from their framework, there's a lot of
things you said there that they're going
to say, "Yes, yes." See, like when you
said it's not a sacrifice, they're
anticipating saying, "Well, it couldn't
possibly be Christ. It couldn't be
typological of Christ because, well,
well, it wasn't sacrificed." And this
gets into the idea that I was saying
earlier about um all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings pointed to the
person of Jesus. The reason two goats
were necessary was because it pictured
for the people not only the penalty for
sin being paid, but the removal of their
sins. Mhm. A single goat couldn't do
that. It's a goat. It's dead. How could
the dead goat then remove the sins? It's
not just about Adventists. It's not just
about sin being paid for. More has to be
done. Restitution has to be made, which
is why there had to be a guilt offering.
The sin has to be removed, expedated.
It was a picture for the person to not
only see the penalty paid but then their
sins take actually taken away. It
required two two goats for that. Which
is why Leviticus 16:5 says that the
scapegoat was a part of the day of
atonement's singular sin offering. There
was a singular sin offering that
involved two goats. One was a sacrifice.
The other was not a sacrifice. Its
function was expeation. The removal of
sins of which involved two goats.
Jesus, however, can be all of the laws,
sacrifices, and offerings in one because
he's far better than a mere animal. He's
the sin offering, the burnt offering,
the guilt offering, the fragrant
offering, etc. I'm going to be doing
some videos on this, but that's the key.
It's there nothing in Leviticus 16,
Adventist, I challenge you, show me
anywhere in Leviticus 16 where it says
anything regarding the scapegoat and
responsibility
that it pictured an individual who is
responsible for sin. that that's not
what's going on there. No, you can look
at I I did a discussion a couple weeks
ago, a few weeks ago with an an
Adventist that wanted to come on the
platform and challenge me on the
scapegoat. So, we brought him on and let
him do it. And he couldn't show me that.
Um, and he had the same issue that every
Adventist I've discussed with on this
has, and that's this idea of assuming it
has something to do with responsibility.
That's not what is in focus there.
Expeation is what's in focus. And get
this, Jim. When I debated an Adventist
pastor on this, I asked him the
question, is the atonement completed
before the scapegoat or after the
scapegoat? He said, after the scapegoat?
All right. So, you believe your
reconciliation to God is done by Jesus
and Satan?
That's what you're saying. That's right.
Okay. And I I said, I just want to have
that on record for everyone to hear. So
when I end up making content about this,
you guys can't cry foul and say, "You're
misrepresenting. You don't know what we
teach." You know, all the excuses I've
heard. You're a Calvinist. Just every
excuse is is eliminated in the fact that
no, that is what you're teaching. That
is what you're teaching. Which is what
we're going to move into momentarily. I
want to look at a quote from Ellen White
and then we're going to look at a
footnote from the fundamental beliefs
book where they speak on Leviticus 16:10
which says that atonement was made on
the scapegoat
because then you ask the question well
the scapegoat's involved in atonement.
So if that's the case then you're saying
Satan's involved in the atonement. So
they have a footnote from one of their
scholars and we'll see what they say in
that. But first, I want to look at what
Ellen White says here
in Christ in his sanctuary, page 181. He
says, quote, "In the typical service,"
talking about Leviticus 16, "The high
priest having made the atonement for
Israel came forth and blessed the
congregation. So Christ at the close of
his work as mediator will appear." Now
Jim,
he's going to end his work as mediator.
Does Hebrews say that he's going to end
his work as mediator? Yeah. Yeah, you're
right. That's another biblical sounding
phrase with no biblical support. No.
Yeah. It says he lives forever to make
intercession for us. Even into eternity,
Christ will forever be the bridge
between God and man, the God man, Christ
Jesus. That's not going to cease in the
future. See, they have this idea, Jim,
that sin is just behavior modification.
Because Ellen taught that at the second
coming, nothing's going to change about
your being. You're essent you're
basically going to be given access to
the tree of life and because you'll be
able to eat from that again which Adam
was barred from, you'll be able to live
forever. But you have to get to
character perfection right now and
demonstrate that you're found worthy of
the new heaven and the new earth and
that you can be trusted to not let sin
enter again. Contrary to Hebrews 12
saying the reason sin will never enter
again is because Christ has purified all
things by the blood of his cross. Um and
that he rules and reigns and that's the
reason. So again, him being mediator
forever. He his mediation entails his
kingly role which they have completely
ignored. They ignore. Yeah. His kingly
role is his mediation for his people.
He's going to rule and reign forever.
Which means he's going to mediate for us
forever, right? There's not going to be
a period of him ceasing mediation and
taking off the Levitical priesthood
garments and then putting on the kingly
garments to now be a conquering warrior,
which is what she said. But
nevertheless, he'll appear with without
sin unto salvation. Hebrews 9:28, of
course, proof texting at a contest. To
bless his waiting people with eternal
life. As the priest in removing the sins
from the sanctuary confess them upon the
head of the scapegoat, so Christ will
place all these sins upon Satan, the
originator and instigator of sin. The
scapegoat bearing the sins of Israel was
sent away unto a land not inhabited.
That's what you were saying about the
wilderness. So Satan bearing the guilt
bearing the guilt of all the sins which
he has caused God's people to commit
will be for a thousand years confined to
earth which will then be desolate
without inhabitant and he will at last
suffer the full penalty of sin in the
fires that shall destroy all the wicked.
Thus the great plan of salvation will
reach its accomplishment in the final
eradication of sin and the deliverance
of all who have been willing to renounce
evil. Close quote. Jim, what are your
thoughts on that?
Um just more of the same. There is
absolutely no biblical support for Satan
bearing the sins when actually when John
1:29
behold the lamb of God who will take
away the sins of the world who bore them
in his body on the cross. Right? This is
behold Satan who's going to take away
the sins of the world. This is
this is just a grand deception on on a
huge scale. And again, anything that
heretical teachings that touch on the
blood of Christ and get it so wrong like
this does is again rising to that level
that I mentioned of 1 John 2:22,
Antichrist.
You are impugning
the the person and work and nature of
Christ. And Ellen White does this
routinely.
I've heard all the mental gymnastics.
I've heard all the excuses. Again, I'
I've been talking with Adventists
basically my whole life, but in this
capacity, not on YouTube, but you know,
just one-on-one, engaging personally in
university, etc. for over a decade. I've
heard all the excuses, the mental
gymnastics to try and get over this.
Adventists, I'm sorry. Christ did not
suffer the penalty for sin in this
system. Satan does. She says he bears
the guilt of all the sins that he caused
people to commit. They've tried to
weasel around this and say, "No, no, no.
It's just the guilt for the sins that
he's caused people to commit. No, no,
no. You have Jesus transferring your
sins if you make it through the
investigative judgment to Satan. Your
sins, not just he's being punished for
his own doings. No, no, no, no. He is
expeating your sins supposedly. Mhm. And
it's Satan who in tandem with Jesus
brings about the accomplishment of
redemption and the actual putting away
of sin. Despite Hebrews 1:4 saying he
made purification at the cross, 9:26
telling us that Jesus put sin away at
the cross. The bearing of guilt for sin
was bore by Jesus. Just like Isaiah told
us, he's the guilt offering.
I I mean
I just It's demonic. It is. It's it's a
demonic teaching. I was talking with one
of my elders about this, trying to
explain this to him. And literally the
only response he had, Jim, was he said
he literally cited back John 129 and
then all he said back to me was what
they're saying is demonic. He said
that's a demonic. He said it's a demonic
teaching. Yeah. and and they struggle to
grasp this. And I there have been times
where I'm talking with them and I'm like
I it just puts skin on the bones that
unless God takes the scales off and you
can see what's being said by this. It's
I understand in the Adventist system
it's like oh no it fits perfectly in my
system. That's not what we're saying.
The whole point is your system is
flawed. This whole there's transference
happening between the two goats in the
sense that the one pays the penalty and
then the other carries the sins away.
That's right. But it's not this idea of,
well, they were transferred to the
sanctuary to then be transferred
eventually to the scapegoat in the end
who's going to bear the penalty for
responsibility. You've got all these
other details that are being weasled in
under the guise of, well, that's what
Leviticus 16 says. No, that's not what
it says. Now, like I mentioned, the
final thing here, Jim, before we call it
quits, all right, thank you for hanging
in here with me. No problem. They
recognize the problem with this in
regards to the scapegoat being involved
in the atonement. Like I mentioned,
Leviticus 16:10, and they have a lengthy
footnote in the fundamental beliefs
book. This is on page 369 for folks who
are interested in it. I will have it up
on screen here obviously. Notice what it
says.
If asale, you mentioned that, Jim, which
the issue around this and the reason
there's some level of confusion, there's
not a ton, but you you're right that
none of them ever mention none of the
four theories ever say anything about it
being specifically Satan. No, the only
one which is coming up primarily from
Jewish apocalyptic sources in the book
of Enoch is that Azazil was the name of
a wilderness demon. A demon, a generic
de a generic demon, right? And that is
even the minority one. When I was
preparing for my debate on this, I read
almost all the Jewish sources that I
could possibly find on this. There are
four primary theories and the problems
stem from the the the the manuscripts
the maseretic texts regarding a
punctuation mark on the the the phrase
aazil
as to whether or not it's referring to
an individual person or if it's
referring to a function place etc a more
generic sort of thing like that but
either way like you were saying none of
them ever say anything about oh it
represents Satan the the SDA church
likes to cling on to this and try and
say well see Jews understood No. No,
they didn't. No. There was folklore
around the idea of it being about a
demon generically, not Satan
specifically. That's right. But they say
here, if Aazil represents Satan, how can
scripture connect him with the
atonement? That's the question they are
answering here because they that's the
question people then ask because
Leviticus 16:10. As the high priest
after having cleansed the sanctuary,
placed the sins on Oazil who was forever
removed from God's people. Except not
really, Jim, because it had to happen
again the next year and the next year
and the next year. It was typological of
the true taking them away permanently.
Who was forever removed from God's
people. So Christ after having cleansed
the heavenly sanctuary will place the
confessed and forgiven sins of his
people on Satan who will then be forever
removed from the saved. This is how
you'll see too where Jim, they don't
cite Ellen White here, but yet they're
quoting what we basically just read from
Great Controversy. That's right. And
Patriarchs and Prophets. So, Ellen
White's just being weasled into this,
but there's no quotation of it, and it's
just a paraphrasing of what she says.
This is how it gets worked in. Now
begins the SDA Bible commentary in the
same footnote.
How fitting that the closing act of the
drama of God's dealings with sin should
be return should be a returning upon the
head of Satan of all the sin and guilt
that issuing from him originally once
brought such tragedy to the lives of
those now freed of sin by Christ's
atoning blood. Thus, the cycle is
completed. the drama ended. Only when
Satan, the instigator of all sin,
is finally removed
can it truly be said that sin is forever
blotted out of God's universe.
In this accommodated
in this accommodated sense, we may
understand that the scapegoat has a part
in the atonement
with the righteous saved, the wicked cut
off, and Satan no more. Then, not till
then will the universe be in a state of
perfect harmony as it was originally
before sin entered. Close quote. Jim,
in an accommodating in an accommodating
sense, right? Satan is a part of the
atonement. Unreal. Yeah. This is the
micro moment right now. To accommodate
is to provide something for someone with
a need. Yeah. So, Satan accommodates
Jesus by being the vehicle for the
expeation of sin ultimately. Right. and
is a um a co-articipator
in the atonement.
I mean that's what this says. I mean
again mic drop moment 7th day adventist.
I mean just read it in your own book. We
may understand that the scapegoat has a
part in the atonement. Hey Dan, those
are not your words, not my words.
That's what it says. You know, I've
heard all the exc. Oh no, you're reading
it wrong. Oh, you're so I'm an idiot is
essentially what you're saying that no
one can understand what's being said
here. We need you to help us interpret
it. Just no. That's what it says. They
have to respond and deal with the fact
that in this theory that these pioneers,
primarily Ellen White, came up with this
is a is a problem that has arisen. So,
okay. Well, how do we deal with the
problem? Well, in this accommodating
sense, at the end of the day, you have
Satan and Jesus accomplishing atonement.
That's the Adventist atonement. Yeah,
that is folks. This is not an alternate
atonement theory. No, like in Mormonism,
they're called spirit brothers. Yes.
Christ, you know, hey, this is the
spirit brothers of Adventism cooperating
in the final atonement. The Adventist
Church does not have atonement
reconciliation to God being completed
until Satan takes the person's sins
away. They can claim all they want.
Yeah, they believe they're reconciled,
forgiven already. Nope. It does not
change the facts as to what the SDA
system of theology says, including the
divinely inspired prophetus. Right? So,
any last thoughts, my friend? Thank you
for hanging out with me this long for
going through this. I think this was a
really important thing. I think this was
really beneficial. Hopefully, people
will find great benefit in this. I know
it was a bit long, but again, these
things are are evergreen and they will
stand the test of time. This stuff isn't
going to change. And so, I really
appreciate you investing in. anything
that you would like to share with people
before you leave? Anything you'd like to
plug or let people know about? Now would
be the time and then I'll let you go and
I will do our sign off. Um, all I all I
have to say is if you're a 7th day
Adventist uh don't give me what I uh use
in my comments a lot. There's a
philosophical uh fallacy, a logical
fallacy called two cokequ and which
means basically yes but no no don't do
yes but there have been many shown
scripture arguments to show Christ paid
for all sin the totality of sin at the
cross. So no yes buts. Deal with the
scripture verses that have been
presented here. And if you want to
engage me personally in the comments,
come hit me on my channel uh Academy
Apologia and deal with the issues. No
two quot.
What about this verse? Uh-uh. Deal with
what was presented to you here that
shows Christ died for sins. Not Satan,
not his spirit brother Satan cooperating
with him to No, no. Christ died for
sins. John 1:29, Behold the Lamb of God
who takes away the sins of the world.
Anyway, this has been long enough, so
I'll I'll let you sign off here. Yeah,
Jim, thank you for being here as always.
We will have to definitely do this
again. Um, again, I appreciate you being
here. And until next time, folks, you
can check him out. Uh his channel is in
the description box as well as I believe
the title of the video it's tagged. So
definitely check his his channel out.
That was a lot. For those of you that
have been here the whole time, you are
awesome. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. The fact that people will sit and
listen to me kind of pour the stuff out
that I've been ruminating on for a
number of years. I didn't start
answering Adventism on a whim, folks.
I get a lot of comments from Adventists
who
and and again I get it. You don't know
anything about me, so it's fair. Um,
I would encourage you if you're an
Adventist to remember that I'm a former
Adventist.
I know all the verses. I know all the
talking points.
I'm not just an outsider. So coming and
just regurgitating the script, what I
call the script back to me when I used
to regurgitate the script myself is not
going to deal with the the issue.
There's a lot that we talked about
tonight. A lot.
If you're an Adventist, we're praying
for you. There are many that we're
praying for by name. You can say what
you want. You can think what you want.
Oh, you're mean. You you hate us. You're
But that's not the case.
It takes a lot of work, folks, to put in
to what we did tonight. I if you'd have
to really have an axe to grind to go
through with the the work and the long
nights and the preparation. It's not
just like, oh, I'm going to turn the
camera on and we're just going to on the
fly. No, that's not what's going on
here. You don't build a website and
write thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands and thousands of
words and hundreds of of articles and
pages
simply because you have an axe to grind.
There's something a lot bigger going on
here, folks. This platform is reaching
people. It's going to continue to reach
people. This gospel is undefeated.
Adventists, you can keep using the
excuse. I hear it all the time, "Oh,
that's because of Calvinism." Nope.
Jim's not a Calvinist.
90% of people who I've had on this
platform with me, they're not
Calvinists.
Philippians 1, Christians are united on
the gospel and who God is because you
have to have the true God to have the
true gospel.
That's not unique to Calvinism.
The other excuse I've I've I've heard,
especially with doing more content now
around atonement, oh that's because
you're a Calvinist. It's only because
you're a Calvinist that you think
atonement being complete that oh so
Lutheran are Calvinists. No, no, folks.
that this what we talked about tonight
is general Christian teaching and
belief.
There's various theories out there.
We're not dogging on saying, "Oh, it's
because of an atonement theory." I hear
that all the time, too, from SDAs. Oh,
you're just nitpicking one theory. No,
no, no. This isn't an alternate theory.
What we talked about tonight is heresy.
And it shows a lack of understanding
around the gospel. The Adventist Church
cannot give you peace with God.
You're not going to have peace with God
through the Adventist church because the
message that they have is not one that
brings peace.
This gospel is life-changing. I get
comments from all sorts of people, not
even just Adventists. We've got Orthodox
viewers, Catholic viewers, Coptic
viewers. They all believe they're the
one true church. I need to come join
them.
But what I I think they may not
understand,
this gospel changed me. there. There's
no uh you're not going to convince me
off of this gospel. This gospel message
changes people. And any person who I've
talked to that encountered this message
and it really sank in their heart, it
changed them.
Now, I don't use that as my proof for
everyone else,
but you're not going to convince me off
of this gospel. This gospel is
undefeated
and we're going to keep heralding this
gospel to a people who are ripe for the
harvest that need to hear this gospel.
Seventh day Adventists
and don't act offended. Your entire
mission as an organization is to
evangelize me and Jim and Christians.
That's your primary focus. The heralding
of the third angel's message is to the
people that are supposedly going to get
the mark of the beast, the Sunday
worshippers.
It's to Christians. So don't act
offended when we turn it back on you and
say, "No, no, no. Listen, the
organization you're a part of is a false
gospel.
It's antichrist. It's against Christ,
and we're willing to take the arrows in
our back despite the costs."
Don't think that this is just an axe to
grind. This is spiritual battle
and we're on the front lines on this
platform. There's people back in the
medic tent at the camp doing that work
and that's necessary as well on the
spiritual battlefield. We're on the
front lines. This is a front lines
ministry. We're getting ready to start
hitting the the boots on the ground this
coming month. Tomorrow is a new month
and big things are in store for this
platform.
You're going to start seeing in the
weeks to come different types of content
rolling out, boots on the ground. You're
going to see us engaging with real
people and Christians are going to see
the individual Joemo 7th Day Adventist
how they were just like I was just like
tons of other Adventists I've talked to
going through the motions no assurance
they don't understand the gospel they're
caught up in this system thinking oh
yeah I've heard all this stuff they
don't have peace with God they don't
know what that's like and the ones that
do claim to to really be dug in on the
SDA theology.
It's just they're really dug in on the
script and the talking points. They
don't actually understand union with
Christ.
I know it's getting late here, but for
those of those of you that want to stay
around, I'm going to do a little talk
here on union with Christ just since
it's up and we were looking at it
earlier.
Folks, this is the hinge
the hinge
of the gospel.
Union with Christ is the hinge of the
gospel. If you do not understand union
with Christ,
you are missing out on the meat of
salvation.
Union with Christ is not only one of the
central doctrines of the Christian
faith, but is the central hinge of the
gospel message. It's through the perfect
work of Jesus Christ on behalf of
sinners that they can be reconciled to
God, have peace with him, and receive
all the benefits that come with that.
This takes place when the Holy Spirit
unites a believer to Christ by faith and
God confers on them all the saving
benefits Christ merited by his life,
death, and resurrection, applying
redemption in full to the individual.
The New Testament authors regularly use
the terms in Christ, in him, in the
Lord, and in Christ Jesus when talking
about the different aspects of this
subject. Combined, these phrases are
found throughout the New Testament over
200 times.
When a person is born again and
regenerated, the Holy Spirit unites the
individual to Christ by faith, taking
them from spiritual death to spiritual
life.
And you were dead in your trespasses and
sins.
The Adventist Church can't deal with
this because the only living aspect of
man is his is his physical being. This
isn't just hypothetical language.
There's a part of your being that is
dead because of your trespasses and
sins.
But then Paul goes on to say here in
Ephesians 2, "But he's made you alive
together with him." It's that dead
aspect of yourself, quickened,
regeneration, being born again. It's not
just about behavior modification. It's
about being a literal new creature in
Christ. My dad often cites 2 Corinthians
5:17 and every time I just think to
myself, man, you're he he quotes it
every time after somebody's baptized.
But they don't actually understand being
made a new creature in Christ is
actually something far more than just
behavior modification.
But it continues where they are are then
made recipients of all the spiritual
blessings that are found in Christ as
mediator and redeemer. It is in this
uniting to Christ that is the source of
believers communion with God as well as
other believers. All believers are
united to one another by virtue of their
union with Christ as one body. That's
how the believers are one body.
And this union lasts throughout all of
eternity. That's why Adventists I'm
regularly harping on how it's not the
church is not confined to a single
denomination. It's not like in Adventism
where it's this idea of we're the one
true church. No, it's universal. It's
not just Presbyterians. It's not just
Baptists. And yes, lo and behold, to
your dismay, yes, that includes Roman
Catholics and Orthodox and the Eastern
Church. There are people united to Jesus
Christ by faith believing this gospel in
all these different branches, including
the Adventist church. There are born
again people in the Adventist church,
and then they eventually end up leaving
because they they start to grow and
understand, holy crap, I can't remain a
part of this. But nevertheless,
when you're raised to spiritual life,
they're then made recipients of all the
spiritual blessings that are found in
Christ as mediator. I read that all
believers are united to one another by
virtue of their union with Christ as one
body. And this union lasts throughout
all of eternity. Without being united to
Christ, one cannot be a recipient of all
of Christ's benefits as they are all
bound up exclusively in him.
Fundamentally, union with Christ is a
phrase of identity. It's how the
believer is to see themselves. They're
hidden in Christ Jesus. So Paul tells us
for you have died and your life is
hidden with Christ in God.
This union consists of three aspects.
Now this is the key.
The eternal, the redemptive and the
existential. Now what are we saying by
this? The eternal union believers have
with Christ is recognized by Paul in
Ephesians 1:4
where he says God chose us in him.
There's that phrase of union before the
foundation of the world.
We see the redemptive aspect in Romans 5
or 6 5-11
where Paul explains that everything
Jesus did in his earthly ministry, he
did as the representative of those that
were chosen in him before the foundation
of the world. This is how the old nature
of the believer could be crucified with
Christ, which is what we're told in
multiple places. and those who belong to
Christ Jesus have crucified the flesh
with with its passions and desires.
For we know that the old self was
crucified with him in order that the
body of sin might be brought to nothing.
This is all talking about union with
Christ. Finally, the existential aspect
is seen in God bringing a person from
spiritual death to spiritual life. This
is the part the Adventist church does
not understand.
Before this takes place, a person is
dead in their sins and trespasses.
It is also this union with Christ that
allows for the great exchange of sin for
righteousness to take place where our
sin was imputed to Christ and he in
exchange imputes his perfect
righteousness to believers.
We're found in him. That phrase of union
not having a righteousness of our own
which is what Jim was talking about
earlier that comes from the law.
Oh, but in Ellen's plan of salvation,
it's through the help of the heavenly
trio that a person can then obey the Ten
Commandments and find favor with God and
receive by Jesus's merits an imputed
righteousness gradually over time that's
imparted to them in small spurts in
accordance with their obedience to the
law. That is not what Paul taught.
It's that which comes through faith in
Christ, the righteousness from God that
depends on faith.
Since they're united with Christ in the
eternal aspect, their sin could be
imputed to him in the redemptive. This
means that Christ atoned for the sins of
his people, the church. Husbands, love
your wives as Christ loved the church
and gave himself for her as then their
sins were placed upon him. Like we
talked about tonight,
the Bible lists all of these as the
benefits. We looked at all of these
earlier. This is the page I brought up.
And these aren't even all of them.
You can access this folks on our
website, union with Christ.
And that's only a sampling of the depth
of this teaching and it's permeating all
of scripture. Upon being united to Jesus
Christ, the believer receives all of the
benefits at that point.
Not all the benefits gradually become.
No, that's not the way that the New
Testament writers, the apostles did not
talk about it this way. Sadly, the
Adventist church does not understand
this key doctrine. Ultimately because
the of their foundational teaching of
the investigative judgment, all roads
lead back to 1844. It is at the behest
of this teaching that they have to fit
the rest of their theological system. In
the investigative judgment, believers
are supposedly on a probationary period
or parole for their final justification
before God to still be determined.
If someone falls into sin, the bond or
union with God is then broken. That's
what they teach. It's hyperl. Check it
out for yourself. That's what Ellen
taught. It's an Ellen quote.
They do not understand the three-fold
aspect of being united to Christ. One of
which being the eternal
union with Christ is an intimate
relationship between God and his people.
There's nothing for God to investigate
because the believer is already hidden
in Christ Jesus. Blameless, holy,
forgiven, accepted, adopted, and
complete. They're already his child, and
he knows them intimately. They're not
disowned by God when they fall short and
cut off from Christ. Rather, God, like a
good parent, disciplines those who are
his when they sin.
For the Lord disciplines the one he
loves and chastises every son whom he
receives.
They remain united to him. And because
they are united, they feel conviction of
sin, something those outside of Christ
do not.
Romans 1 through3.
In this investigative judgment, however,
there are still things that can condemn
a person like the Ten Commandments. In
contradiction to Romans 8:1, those who
are in Christ Jesus, there's that phrase
of union. There is no condemnation
because the law would have to be able to
condemn Christ.
In contradiction to Romans 8:1 saying
that those who are united to Christ
cannot be condemned by anything. This is
because the law cannot condemn Christ
and that's who believers are hidden in.
They're dead to the law. That's what
that means. It doesn't mean, oh, we're
free to live lawlessly.
No, it's meaning that the law cannot
condemn us because it would need to
condemn Christ. The law is still a
righteous standard to look to in terms
of morality for I shouldn't lie because
God's not a liar, but it's not a
barometer for if you're going to make
it.
The law had no provisions, folks, for
forgiveness. And the Adventist church
doesn't ever talk about this. The
Adventist understanding is that, well,
Christ came to show us that the law can
be kept, and he gave us a second doover
on the old covenant. No. No. Christ
fulfilled the old covenant perfectly
such that he can impute to you the
standing that he has as if it's you've
kept the law perfectly already. That's
what freedom in Christ is. You're now
free to actually live a life pleasing to
God. Yes, we get up each day. I
catechize my son. We go to church
weekly. We're praying. We're not just
seeking to live lentiously.
That's the extreme that the response is
that's brought in to oh, so you're just
saying people can live however they
want. No, we're talking about new
creatures in Christ. It's that each day
it's not my obedience to the ten
commandments that I'm looking to to
maintain my justification like the
Adventist prophetist taught which is on
the page regarding justification for
those that want to see the quote.
The law could only condemn believers if
it could condemn Christ. In this
investigation, Christ is supposedly
going over the record books of heaven to
see who truly is and isn't his out of
those who have professed faith. This
investigation is to see which ones are
shown to be entitled to the atoning
benefits of his sacrifice.
So notice in Ellen's theology, it's only
after the investigative judgment is
complete and you've made it to the point
of being finally justified that you're
then entitled to the benefits of Christ
sacrifice.
Don't tell me Adventists that you guys
understand with Christ and we believe
that we say in him. That's what Jim was
saying about in the book. There's a lot
of Christian ease and a lot of fluff
without a lot of substance and
understanding about how this phrase is
used throughout the Bible.
Folks, this is the core of the gospel.
You need to understand this. I don't
care what tradition you're a part of.
This is the core crux of the gospel.
It continues, "A single unconfessed sin,
yes, a single unconfessed sin will cut
off one from Christ and separate their
soul from God." That's what Ellen said.
Again, this would mean that something
could condemn a person who's in Christ,
which would lead to them not being
united to him anymore. Contrary to
scripture, Christ already knows those
who are his and they are united to him
and he will lose none of those people
because it's the father's will that he
not. I know people don't like it. You
can broad brush it with whatever you
want and say whatever you want. Deal
with the text. The will of the father
was that the son would be sent by the
father and he would lose none of those
that he came for. Adventists Christ did
not come for a nameless faceless group.
He came for his sheep. He a people he
intimately knows
not a nameless faceless group to open a
door and make something a possibility.
It was the will of the father that Jesus
come and lose none of those that were
given to him.
He does so successfully. They were given
to Jesus by the father and chosen from
the before the foundation of the world.
If the believer is already holy,
blameless and seated with Christ in
heaven by virtue of being united to
Christ and nothing can condemn them,
there's nothing for Jesus to be
investigating. Believers already possess
the benefits of Christ. Oh,
believers already possess the benefits
of Christ's atonement by being in him.
This strikes a straight blow to the
investigative judgment. Sadly, the SDA
church's lack of understanding around
this foundational biblical teaching is
part of the evidence that they have a
false gospel and cannot save that cannot
save and they do not understand the
actual good news of Jesus Christ. So,
Adventists, we're praying for you. This
train is not going to stop. We're not
even a year in. We have a lot of good
stuff in store. Again, for you folks who
have partnered with us financially, I
just want to thank you guys again.
We're still young in this. The fact that
you would do that is incredible. I
appreciate the heart from people all
over the world. It just it's crazy, you
know, here from my house and yeah, it
it's just it's wild. I did not
anticipate all this in a year's time.
And so, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
If you want to partner with us, you want
to share your testimony, wall of memes,
all that sort of stuff, make sure to
check out answering adventism.com. I'm
losing my voice, so that's the
indicator. I've been talking way too
much, but again, for you who stuck
through this the entire night. Uh, big
ups to you. Kudos to you. Thank you to
you guys. We will see you uh next week.
I'll be here solo. We'll be responding
to Ted Wilson. It's going to be on a
Friday night, not Thursday. I'll
actually be golfing with my dad uh on
Thursday, so I won't have time. Um and
so we're actually going to do it on
Friday instead. We're going to be
responding to Ted Wilson and a talk he
gave on why are there so many
denominations?
My question in that stream is going to
be why are there so many errors, Ted?
Why are there so many errors? So, we
will be doing that next Friday. And then
the week after that, Richard Foster,
former Adventist, is going to be on here
with me. We're going to be responding to
uh Dennis PBY. uh he's a big last
generation theology guy, but um that'll
be a great stream for a number of
reasons. So, some good stuff in store.
But as always, Adventists, our call to
you, like your call to us would be to
come out of her, my people. You would
say that uh the her there is Babylon,
that we're part of Babylon. We would say
that you're part of Ellenism. And you
need to come out of her, come to know
the true Christ and his gospel. As
always, until next time, God bless.
[Music]